all right and we are both live the last
word with the newly minted DCP sponsors
what is going on sir oh man yeah
definitely got a pretty awesome thing
happened last night so yeah I got to be
on destiny community podcast shout-out
to mr. AR 3s who's in here this morning
apparently you don't sleep much either
but ya got to hang out with an awesome
group if you guys have been living under
a rock for some reason I got to chat
with it was Pope Bear was kind enough to
invite me on and then Steph TTFN which
many of you guys have probably seen a
lot of these guys started the kind of
playing at destiny whole group and then
they kind of shifted off to make DCP so
it's ft2 briar rabbit Holtzman of course
miss 5,000 watts and Poe fair all five
of them it was so much fun so had a good
time
and I got my face out there now so the
face reveal is legit unmasked yeah so
that was pretty cool
[Music]
and all in all just had a really really
good time so they're just a fun group
had a good time I feel like my cheeks
hurt after a little rock because y'all
have a foot yeah they were just like
they're their Twitter questions are
absolutely ridiculous yes they get
really crazy out there it's like and I
love fallout what I was looking through
the questions fallout even asked them
was like so what is your favorite cereal
and please explain why people who pour
milk first have no souls I'm just like
crit Diane before it even starts so no I
was really cool and I got to see Captain
Marvel last night like right after it so
like a pretty much a midnight show got
out of there literally it was 10:30
walking out of there at almost 2:00 so
it was late late night but had an
awesome time and then waking up to get
back into this one
so sir how you doing this availa I'm
trying to not trying to not hog anything
here just you know okay to accept your
newfound stardom and I'm here too
celebrate I was very proud very proud
just see about boy out there he was
doing it up and I shout the Vagabond Oh
in your chat he was in there too like it
was just so cool to see your community
like in that chat as well and just like
Alvin eyes and we know just see it was
just really cool to see because you know
as I said before and I tweeted it
you know DCP you know shelter those guys
like and gal like they are amazing
that's the rock that is the Mount
Rushmore and I'm listening to them for
so long and they just have great
chemistry carry personalities and it was
just good to see them you know kind of
plot your journey and then you got you
kind of integrate with them and that was
dope so shout out to them great show if
you guys have not watched it please this
was the big one this was the Destiny
Super Bowl my boy was there he was on my
Super Bowl it's like I was in there it's
like for them I'm another guest but no I
was that was a big deal for me I was
like I was actually nervous all day
getting ready beforehand and stuff like
that and just kinda hide so it was it
was a big deal for me absolutely red
shout-out to you guys hi Brit he said he
had a good laugh at a red to gifted sub
I had a good laugh if funny you say that
hyper because I had a good laugh
I couldn't believe briar read my
question I was like oh boy gave you a
shout-out I felt good of a warm as I
couldn't I could not not do that I mean
you and I've been doing this is number
52 this is officially a year's worth I
mean never feels like a year but 52 is
actually cuz I mean like 50 hundred
those are standard milestones but 52 is
52 weeks on misses we've been at it for
a year we've been chatting off and on
for years so I mean there's no I
couldn't could not shout you out in
there a couple times because that's part
of the comfort of the podcast comes from
just chatting with you we do this all
the time so it honestly probably just
helped me be able to hold my own in
there what you did fantastic you did
fantastic
it was great to see like I said the
topics are great everything floating
like I said just to see your what your
hard work being celebrated
it's always great to see so salute prama
that's that was a good one Mary
thank you very much no doubt sheet in
the building so uh real quick um just
yay or nay I just need a thumbs-up
thumbs-down we ain't gonna do no
spoilers but I'm gonna see Captain
Marvel or not Saturday I heard some
things do I get the thumbs-up do I get
the thumbs down do I get the thumbs
sideways well like what I get I enjoyed
it I had fun okay okay cool cool cool
that's all I mean that's literally like
I mean there are some fun bits in there
and there's a certain things like if you
go watch a couple interviews with brie
Larson and kind of understanding more on
the character there's certain things I
was even telling my wife they're like oh
you should have smiled more and she's
like that's not the character like
there's certain dumb things interviews
that people were saying it's just like
go watch it go have fun I mean I
wouldn't put it at the top of my Marvel
list but honestly it's like it's it's
it's own thing it's in the 90s it's
definitely got some good nostalgia bits
to it
she definitely like it's I don't know I
had fun I enjoyed it it's it's a it's a
good movie like I'll be curious what you
think but it was like I had a fun time I
mean I was like I was waiting for like
an Avengers preview or anything like
that but no I was like just stay through
the credits as always it's Marvel and
all I gotta say is like yeah she's she's
something so I would say it's a T thank
you for that man but yeah for me other
than that has been the same ol same ol
you know prepping and stuff like that
because unique website all that good
stuff and then just getting grinding
with podcasts and everything but yeah
it's been a summer season of The Drifter
action you know saying I've been uh
definitely knee deep and now I got a
chance to play a lot and I want to shout
out my my bro Lord addict is now PC
master-race
you got his uh you got his a rake man so
he's trying to get him up he's in his
kindergarten phase so he got him to the
um the forsaken DLC whatever whatever
but funding is the power surge bodies
don't work for him until he gets the
level 15 oh you have to be 50 for the
kick in yeah
we found that out the hard way because
we like oh it's gonna be easy he could
just jump
the game of crime with us and they do
actually want you to like play and
experience
yeah that's unlike work your way up a
little yeah because he had the booster
forsaken boost no no
yeah to like level 30 so he can at least
start forsaken campaign but being that
we were on I'm thinking he could just
grab the drifters power surges to just
wireless recordings enrolled yeah so
just just a word to the wise for those
who are buying destiny for the first
time because of this content you still
gotta play a little that was a doozy
giving Xbox the Forsaken abandoned read
less severe you guys step your game up
brother this is this is the frames man
gotta get over here days it's nice over
you too what is nice not too bad that
too late minute works pretty on these PC
Street yesterday that's pretty much big
for me I'm dead doing a lot of that you
know salves you touch division last week
didn't get a chance to play much anthem
we'll get into patches of her things and
you know yeah but it is very bad right
now I'm not saying it should happen I'm
doing yeah that's it's an issue but it's
not quite as bad but it's still bad yeah
you know I'm kind of just waiting for
the dust to clear on that
before I jump back in cuz I obviously
yeah we're gonna talk about it we had a
big patch coming now and yeah man so
let's get into what's going on man we
got a lot to talk about
yeah so this week's is the drifter
obviously if you play this needle
launched and we had a patch that
actually came first so we are gonna
start there mmm-hmm so update two point
two point O is a thing some good changes
some interesting changes definitely some
PvE meta changes PvP I don't know if it
changed that much I honestly only played
mayhem a little bit because that's my
easy way to get my games of the week
yeah have some fun while I do it as
opposed to go do you like quick play or
something so I was like I gotta I should
probably do that for some powerful gear
Oh a man sweet I'll do that so I'll just
you know kill some time yeah but the
towers changed we've got the drifters
relocated in DD annex since apparently
we know he's gonna be used a lot I guess
they want to put him closer to landing
zone so
mmm-hmm makes life a little bit easier
clans got some changes yeah
so what do you think about the whole
getting back to the getting back to the
old system you you all right with this
as far as I'm when you say the old
system you mean it's literally doing
activities and getting clean experience
okay I got no daily no daily bounties
and stuff yeah I'm fine with it I'm
founded I mean just play how you kind of
want and then um you know you got some
specialized things in conjunction I
don't really have I mean they they all
forcing you know you play with camp
remedies for certain things to get you
know certain perks and I know we will
talk about it but the level 5 in level 4
perks really excite me that is more
stuff I kind of want to see so yeah I
mean I'm ok with it I'm ok what about
you in general I mean yeah that's so one
of those things I don't think they
needed to change like the daily bounties
would have been a nice addition like
even if it was just one or something to
be like and if it had a decent rotation
but the daily banners were literally
always except for I think out of a ton
it was always game but crucible game
it'd be first of all it's like like hey
go do a strike or hey go do a nightfall
with like just random stuff they could
mix up the variety and that's one of
those things in this game that still
always kind of makes me question how
much I know certain things I'm not a
developer I'm not gonna say it but a
little more variety in all things it's
generally gonna be good so like a couple
more types of bounties I'm sure we'd see
them all but it's like all I would see
is like the same three or four it felt
like so yeah not having to worry about
oh let me go pick up my daily bound it's
just going to do stuff also absolutely I
like that then yeah the clay and perks
are cool like Jan said enhancement
chords mod components for both of those
and then the strike catalyst you're
talking about that's definitely a good
thing that's big-time I gotta get my I
think huckleberries a couple that's tied
today and war cliff coil I believe is
tied to that you're gonna well we'll get
to it but you're gonna talk about these
updates yeah yeah I got a lot of real
life data to discuss so yeah clans got a
little tweak mostly for the better from
what I can tell and I don't think it's
going to be too hard with all the stuff
going on if you play
the game you'll get some clean exp so
that's good sandbox we have some changes
to say the absolute least and shout out
to fallout plays and both detto for
there oh yeah numbers testing
I saw dados I didn't see fallout 4
losses I don't feel I must be so yeah
follows will handle basically PvP and
daddo handled PvE so they both put out
some awesome uh kind of covering both so
basically the gist of the PDP is that
range is a bit shorter basically his
thing was before was like nine meters
for that prime yet ranged you know
single-shot basically those are
generally he said it has happened so
it's not like it never does but
consistently it's about eight meters
instead of nine for those single shots
um BP based on my experience I would
agree however this one gun that is
breaking that rule and rightfully so
based on its an exotic chaperone oh no
God I'm waking up in nightmares bro I'm
scared covers that that one's out till
all these it's a simple yeah it's 11 but
if you have the perk from one kill he
said it was like a 13 meter like single
shot so it's it's covering some ground
chaperones I mean I'm terrible with it
the sub kick is good oh then that's
where yeah it's um yeah it's really
really rough out there so if anybody if
y'all go with the chaperone this is the
time to use it it is definitely breaking
that nerve I mean roughly Sully's and
exotics exotic slot
yes onyx slug to like yeah mister if you
miss the slug you don't and so
absolutely so yeah that's definitely
definitely want to keep in mind but
general like you know they tried to
balance and then when data was going
through said it felt like there were
some more options from normal exotics
parcel of Stardust he said it was a bit
of a surprise from being like a little
better than you expected yeah legend of
a curious is back in peace territory but
to you able your favorite the Lord of
wolves
[Music]
all praises due to the law is putting
out some there because you get five
shots it's easier to hit those single
bullet crits as opposed to a spread and
it puts out some damage so I mean if you
do loon affections or rally barricade on
some bosses and it's got a little
difference to it if you can get in that
shotgun range you can pump out some
damage so that was actually be the top
dog of the damage surprisingly so that
was a cool shot it'd be a curious to be
on no right surprised rockers would be
the undefeated you know champ with that
so it just made me seem because um you
know my love for Lord of wolves right I
always told you about that right like
Lord of wolves I mean you know you you
know about my love for sleeper but Lord
of wolves indeed won it in its initial
form I like the concept of it which was
they try to make you run like a pack of
fallen and it would give the people
around you a plus um two or three
recovery or something yeah am i right
yep true story I got to the only time I
got to the lighthouse that was in my
loadout
yo bro I don't know what a people would
even know addict and since they would
say yo you are so good with that gun in
PvP like it's something about I just
play well with it and because I got it's
like a short-range pulse so to speak and
I'm just happy to see it but now it's
about PC deck now I'm gonna grinding
nothing but spider bodies I have to get
but what the Lord of wolves back that's
that's my baby I gotta get it but I
gotta get Acuras back too but uh it was
good to see I saw that dad old video
very hype to see that the you know
shotguns in PvE they're in a better
place so uh yeah man but what else we
got what if yeah uh submachine guns base
damage increased slightly precision
damage decreased slightly which is kind
of weird I guess some say about that you
got sandbox man yeah I got I got no I
just got some like real world
application um yeah if you guys have
been playing gambit prime here's the
Cognito tip of the week
Oh get that if you're able to get it
even if you don't get to curate it get
that bug out um what is it oh it's a new
sub its bug out something please help me
check yeah noted
it's some yummy I don't know yeah I'll
tell you right now pull up the madam and
all that good stuff tomato
it's a 900 rpm sub machine and I'm gonna
tell you right now it is nasty in
crucible it the bug out bag got it bug
out bag oh boy I'm telling you her and
III got one accurate erode I got a one
that doesn't even have that greater roll
it is yo subs I don't know maybe that
sub machine but it's really really
strong I was mowing people down that
just let you know so yeah just shout out
there so you might want to dust off the
900 rpms see how they go give here
haven't give our heroes burden a shot
yet cuz it's Connie in that same
archetype in PvP subs okay a little
differently stay fell to me least a
specific one so give it a shot hmm yeah
so submachine guns check them out
speaking of the pinnacle weapon being
pretty powerful for crucible so that's
definitely a thing the recluse people
it's given things some people like oh
I'm gonna grind game at prime there were
certain like content creators be like
I'm doing nothing but getting like said
pinnacle weapon mmm-hmm shut up to said
fret Steve French in my check for the
Twitter I'm so by the way good more from
from across the pond over there and UK
machine guns what was gonna happen yeah
it was not looking forward to it though
have you have you tried them oh yeah how
you feel about it they still do work
they still have a lot of bullets but
they're not quite as godly as they were
now I was using the Hammerhead
thunderlord might be a little more
powerful with the lightning strikes but
yeah definitely feels like it lost a
little bit on their punches I'm fully
agree if I fit I felt the weakness in it
and I'm just I haven't I'm scared to
touch the Lord as a result I know I
actually haven't usually completely gone
I do the majesticness have done the Lord
want to see it you know any less but
yeah right now hammerhead is then Prime
Evils - laughing at me bro I was like
it's not it's not a good good look right
now so yeah so yeah machine guns are not
quite the be-all end-all which is good
for a variety but yeah it's kind of one
of those that I wish it wouldn't have
been so the amber reserves got nerfed by
half because you could have 311 for
thunderlord 340 I think for hammerhead
so the reserves or bananas okay
absolutely absolutely so I mean that's
that I could kind of see more but the
reduced damage against boss and
mini-bosses by 21% is definitely felt
without yeah let me say one thing a
shout to the chat shout out dizzy and
shouted Shadow King he said the new
pinnacle machine gun is a monster look
it's still good for invading I feel so
machine guns are still good in PvP and
invading in gambit but if you're talking
about pure DPS to a boss you know you
know say a new cap King is 700 so you
know and that's one of those things when
I did one of my one of my solo runs on
shattered throne I used thunder Lord so
part of that was like you know making
sure I had max ammo which that'll be a
little bit lower and the damage is
reduced by 20% it's like I could
one-phase it with well of radiance but I
don't know if I could one phase it now
so it's definitely gonna take more
probably two cycles and stuff by the one
phasers are gonna be harder for a couple
other reasons coming up we have as well
so yeah next week whose shadow throne
comes back which will be a good way to
get some gear I'm definitely not gonna
be still gonna have probably due to
Michael on board yet and that's still
the hardest fight in there so I'm just
thinking through stuff that I've done
changes some stuff up some absolutely
trace rifles how honest I haven't
touched him yet PvE damage increased by
30% that's pretty substantial oh yeah
shout out to I suggest you guys get that
prometheus lens and to me prometheus
feels better than cold heart it's just
that cold heart right now when you're
doing single target dps is overall
better but prometheus right now is a
yellow bar and AD clearing machine dust
off Prometheus you I'm telling you right
now touch that it feels
really good right now that 30% yeah so
I'm gonna have to just dig into the
vault and see what the heck is uh it
hasn't been used but yeah Prometheus
with that well especially if you get
that nice glowing orb getting bigger and
bigger I can see that thing putting in
plenty of work so it will happen to see
really good grenade launchers haven't
used them much but you got PDE damage
increased by 25% which is a chunk they
keep trying to find this place for
grenade launchers and I don't know if
it's ever gonna feel like they're worth
it they got reserve amo getting boosted
in most cases grenade launchers gained
about 3 rounds and reserves so if you
have like grenade launcher scavenger and
reserves perks on your armor you're
gonna be holding a lot and if you can do
something like rally barricade most of
those drum grenade launchers can put out
a ton of damage I know I was running
what I did like it was a solo nightfall
on warden of nothing for example and got
to the I was using prospector it's like
19 grenades into the boss like if I had
a full clip dead mm really I got and
that was before this buff that was last
week so I mean 25% damage is definitely
something you'll notice because I used
the full 19 and that had a little
reserves in it 25% that's that's just
faster so magazine perks and mods and
there were some things quick access
sling was not being applied so now
malicious birth right with quick access
laying her ass across talking about
thing that thing's just gonna be nasty
so I love when he says an ad like that
word like there's certain words he says
it just cracks me up
it's nasty and how excited he gets like
when we go out to a Garnica I gotta be
CrossFit like he is hilarious I love
listening to his weapon breakdown I tell
you boys it's gonna be nasty
Crosby yeah so I don't have mountain top
but I do have malicious birth right so
I'm like that would probably be pretty
good too
absolutely but all I know yeah grenade
launchers I mean they are giving more
weapons viability a couple things
probably
that happened I'm not thrilled about
them because I love my machine guns but
it's like now there are a couple that
we'll talk about in a minute that I feel
like I'd hit harder than they needed to
be but we'll get there
rocket launchers damage increase we
talked about it before 60 puts a 65%
increase in damage cluster bomb damage
is reduced but the initial impact from
rocket launchers definitely a big buff
so you can definitely get some more
chunks in there for sure something like
two-tailed Fox with the doubles oh I
could only a Mac can't wait to get my
hands on that and yeah got it I gotta
bring it out to you gotta bust that off
cuz I remember you gotta often we're
gonna I got its own buff I think on top
of that when we get to it
yep linear fusion rifles PvE damage
increased by 10% does not affect sleeper
because exotics they're kind of doing
their own tweaks to it reduced aim
assist or do removed aim assist bonus
from combat sight scopes and fix dish or
a cream queen breaker had double aim
assist so yeah 200% aim assist like oh
I'm looking in their direction magically
I just killed them cool mm-hmm that
should at least be a little little
harder to do so linear fusions are fun
though I mean there's points where if
there's like a void cinch and I bring
out crooked Fang in heavyweights on oh
man it's just just broken oh yeah and
trikes and stuff like that with like a
void cinch and heavy weight crooked
thing is just doing plenty of work so
it's it's kind of awesome right exotics
PvE damaged for two-tailed Fox speaking
of increased by 26% with thousand voices
in top of the 60 just to just clarify
work
26 on top but at 60 the base alright
sorry are you sure cuz I thought they
were saying like exotics were tweaked
differently oh you may be right yeah you
may be right maybe I don't know but
that's one thing I feel like I've heard
now 1,000 voices has a bug right now
what's up there looking at it
PvE damage increased by 25% but if you
have 1,000 voices your primary energy
weapon also are increased by 25%
oh yeah it's kind of broken so if you
have a thousand voices guess what you
are just kind of gonna kill some stuff
faster everywhere you just so if you see
voices in-game at prime or anything
you're may as well just
ah crap Wow didn't know that Wow yep so
that's the thing
there were you're not a match for it but
I never heard a date on it yet
you know Ella to shackle shotgun on
Twitter she always has the breakdown of
basically everything so I caught that in
one of her little summaries of the day
yep and now the big boy of always worth
PVE damage increased by a hundred and
fifteen percent against boss combatants
and scaling up to a hundred and sixty
percent against the weaker combatants
Jesus so my advice word clip oil yeah I
don't have it on PC that's a really oh
man I don't have I'm les I'm waiting for
user video as soon as we get off because
um if he's not coil if he's got to this
the first time like I'm like I wouldn't
be mad if he had coil it wouldn't be an
old W it wouldn't be a new Forsaken
exactly but coil is that good right now
so uh yeah that that's on the list man
absolutely
mm-hmm yep so that's definitely one of
those and especially with the catalyst
the tracking on that thing definitely
gets a big boost I don't know if you've
seen videos with that one but the
catalyst is worth grinding for because
this thing apparently now is gonna be
putting in a lot of work well I'm tellin
probably like my least use exotic ever
25 20 15 percent projectile increase on
damage that's one of those I'm just like
okay I mean I'm not gonna this even is
like I'm still not gonna pull it out on
my vault I mean are you even whether you
have it or not would you even consider
so not at black tile and I have a time
I've gotten a broken I don't know I'm
not using that I just can't
snorts I don't know swords in d1 the
exotic swords in d1 were truly like
awesome like the uppercut for I can't
even remember the fire one dart drinker
is the one everyone really waste no
please lighter I think that's it yeah
that's the cylinder is lighter and there
was the young wolf for Verizon oh yeah
that one was weak well yeah I was raised
later and then dark drinker I mean we
just haven't had a sword that feels like
that the ammo hasn't
there and then on top of that it's the
just they don't have something cool
about him is they still just swing them
mmm
shout the August laser swords are good
with stronghold no that's the new exotic
Newport I don't know I don't know I'm at
I think cuz there is a new exotic that a
Titans have that when you um you hold
you get this indefensible thing and
energy recovery it's a really good new
exotic flora season a drifter and
apparently it's Titan only looks it
looks really sick yeah I actually
haven't dug into what the new exotics
are I should definitely go see what the
data forming says it must be strong
mobile cuz ogre just say yep that's the
new Titan exact that's what he's doing
well you know new exotics are gonna be a
while in the making but we'll get to
hopefully seeing some others here's
where the changes start happening whoa
sleeper simulant reduced ammo reserves
from 13 to 9 without armor perk so your
base max ammo reserves is down to nine
it's like why do they keep beating up on
my boy like this like we've already got
the 10% linear fusion rifle buff that we
didn't get right sleepless simulant was
excluded you know I get what the aim
assist it's like ah like this one is
just like I thought we were okay I
thought we did everything we could do to
this weapon we have to still keep but
you know what we'll get to the next one
oh it's like the next ones worse whisper
of the worm reduced ammo reserves from
20 down to 9 Wow
I was like it's in half and then some oh
wow and that's so I know okay so if you
always making shots yeah you'll have
infinite ammo sure but I will also say
the registration is not always there
like whether I feel like I hit the crit
and it doesn't count it or I feel like I
do and it doesn't always give me the
three back you have to net you have to
mess ups or glitches or whatever and
you're out late 21st night per rifle
especially for a heavy sniper rifle you
know if you miss your shots it's
definitely more of a skill weapon now
but man that is rough
I think with perks you might be able to
get up to 12 so you might get more but
that's pretty brutal to cut that mo yeah
I mean even sleeper it takes for this
one takes 11 out of the that's just it
hurts you know the only thing I got it I
got a defend my sleeper users is that at
least with you guys you whisper guys if
you're accurate you're gonna get that
white nail you know I mean you're gonna
get some stuff back there as with us
it's just like you know
tough luck man better they're like the
only thing I'm thinking about now is
shout-out to esoteric he's got a video
up right not too long ago where he's um
soloing catalysts and easy show he saw
some cool ways so I think I might try to
get the catalyst was sleeper more than
ever because that actually increases
that ammo reserve nonetheless to charge
time so um yeah about that
yeah you know I definitely need to do
that that's sleeper catalyst is one a
charge time if nothing else but all good
but the charge stuff would be really
worth it absolutely yep absolutely
so to your name heaven I don't the
tyranny hobo can now drop with
randomized perks is that the one from
last wish is that right yeah because
that's the only one I don't know
actually leave so Risa mmm-hmm some
other general weapon fixes things like
that most of its pretty low-key
I said rapid hit on sniper rifles would
activate twice on a precision kill so
rapid hit on snipers do was doing the
little extra work they tweet swords a
little bit tweak the lane monarch bow so
it's actually working correctly by the
way shadow to yotan whenever you do get
that gun for killing envoys and gambit
Prime nasty dude it's like 1 maybe 2 and
I can hold about 15 because it's an
energy and I can put some work in with
that gun still invade and put a little
bit in like that paired with a machine
gun gives me some nice variety of
options for both invasion and PvE
killing as well so yeah yo tson and
hammerhead have been my gambit premarin
yes I gotta get that yes it's honestly
rng in one of the forges but
yeah it's there they did some other
tweaks and patches and things like that
abilities I'm not gonna go through all
the little ones in case there's if
there's anything specific let me know
call it out
Titan skating has been reduced whoo so
all the PC Titan skaters has been it's
less effective they're not able to
completely break it but it's better and
then also the infinite super for the
code of Justin who needed to happen I
mean it seemed fun in theory but if you
can break like an entire like strike and
just keep shoulder charging enemies
there's something not quite right about
that and i you know ii i played titan a
lot and it was fun but it's not meant to
stay yeah agreed
and then hand-held supernova a little
warlock fix as well mm-hmm uh handheld
supernova did not properly render while
invading in gambit there's I guess just
too much going on the screen they kind
of broke it so mm-hmm
and then we've got armor so you to armor
will now drop with a random stat package
heavy restorative or mobile which is
good it's not like one set is like if
this one is always gonna be heavy or
mobile so if you do like a look but
you're waiting for that heavy for a
little more of a stat run you actually
can get a little more variety there
which is good because not saying it
really makes that much of a difference
but having a random stat roll there if
you do like the way that set looks at
least gives you a little more options if
you're going for that okay now the
exotics one-eyed mask finally getting
tweaked we talked about it before 15
seconds down to eight seconds for the
market duration and health no longer
restores automatically but slowly over
time can no longer be triggered a while
and superest you're not just unkillable
right how long did this take to get done
yeah I took a while that's AG well I'm
glad seven months yeah Titans gotta feel
a little bit you know skating and uh
when I'm asked that was that was the
move out there you know kind of bring
you back in line it's a little bit I've
got carries horn somebody was like
tweeting about this one so you get out
let me know if what I'm missing here
increased class energy gain from solar
damage kills from ten to 15% introduced
the cooldown from two to one second
solar blast ground
now returns a second ground ground
follow back toward the player damage
from ground follow increases from eighty
to a hundred damage from ground fall is
doubled in PvE I don't even remember how
this exotic works do you have a yeah
that was that one with the increase that
one it was a helmet in all three what in
classes got it I want to say it was that
one but um it was like no the you're
talking about those three where they
kind of buff each other yeah wasn't that
one no that one
a on it's the let's see solar this is a
exotic helmet for it's a Titan actually
trying to remember solar damage kills
recharge your barricade yeah it's a time
which unleashes a blast of solar energy
winds summoned mmm okay so yeah I I even
remember doing a serve video about that
I was like so I put up my barricade and
a little blasts of solar engine like I
never tested it to know how good or bad
it was but it seems like yeah not really
Esper of radius
damage increase from 70 to 100 damage is
tripled in PvE yeah guy I was funny as I
just got that as a drop on like my first
day playing on Susan a drifter
first exotic job in a while I can
literally got it back so I gotta test it
out I haven't gonna put it to the paces
yet
basically what Vespa does is if you're a
warlock it should theoretically be good
in something like prime and reckoning
because yeah it works to win you get
surrounded by more than like two enemies
your rift energy comes back almost
instantly it starts to charge up super
fast so you're constantly getting rifts
now the initial part of it is when you
push the rift down it sends out a
lightning charge to kill like weaker
enemies like you'll kill thralls with it
yeah so that was the way it was but now
they saying damage is tripled dad I got
a test out dad yeah and that'll be as
you said like fer our new wonderful you
know activity with a whole bunch enemies
in it well
you know rift rift blast blast survive a
little longer get your energy back
faster yeah that's gonna be like a nice
variety of an option at least for me
without my plan on utilizing it is going
to be I don't have Phoenix protocol yet
so I'm gonna try to bust that out on um
you know well a radiance class and I'll
have my well and I have my Vespa for
fast riff so I'm constantly getting
riffs and healing I'm gonna try to try
right now I'm in the process of making a
loadout for gambit primed with Vesper
until I get a protocol so I'm dying to
test it out I'll practice out after the
show
we've got seal de home cars grasp now
procs from smoke bomb damage Nerissa
furiosa no longer counts self damage to
void shield and calculating how much
energy to give back which is good I'm
not sure how I self damage my own shield
but that's the thing I guess
and in tailless Ward's fix an issue
where improved slide was not
consistently applying within tailor
swords which is a big deal because
that's just all about sliding uh
accessory fixes nothing major there
rewards general basics we've got power
cap up to 700 Oh several bounties may
give only a maximum possible power award
from this season in which they were
acquired so they definitely tamed it
down for future seasons to wear powerful
gear powerful bounties anything like
that is gonna give you stuff that's
related to the season that it's in so
you can't carry over you know iron
banner bounties they definitely nerved
or you know ascendant challenge bounties
anything that you would carry forward is
gonna be pretty minimal and then a raid
Keys as well they limited it to 5 so a
max of like basically one run mm-hmm
let's see crucible updated valor and
glory emblems to track only the current
seasons rank accomplishments little
stuff like that vendors got some updates
[Music]
these we don't need to go through in
full detail shacks drifters of all they
have their pinnacle weapons so
definitely go check out checks has got a
new scout rifle but when we talked about
last week so that's the oxygen sr3
drifter it's gonna be you're gonna be
spending time there anyway and we'll get
to that
and in Zavala also little tweaks there
now shout out to Zavala I don't know
when we'll get there specifically but
that nightfall card has changed really
oh yeah
so to get your hundred thousand points
score you're gonna need back need to get
back closer to that max light level
because if you run because there's a
hundred ten point modifier when you were
running season to the forge so 110 from
650 and if I ran you know like two buffs
and 2d buffs I would be like a 5 point I
don't know five point five someone
something ridiculous modifier where
points were not any issue right on the
other side now if I were a 110 boy
modifier it's like a two maybe
so it's really low so you really so now
if I if I bump it up to 160 which would
be the cap at like 700 to take me down
to 540 the nightfall levels it takes it
to a 4.0 5 modifiers which I was which I
used to run like just about everything
yet and you can get that but that's with
like match game blackout heavyweight and
the singe so definitely gonna be some
time before that hundred thousand drops
I mean esoteric me do it tomorrow who
knows but for most of us normal people
it's definitely gonna be a little harder
especially soloing for sure oh yeah
absolutely so that's definitely gonna be
a thing if you're grinding those things
out it's gonna take a little while and
then sir has the possibility of selling
Forsaken so yeah that video coming out
at 11 is gonna have to fold this week is
just about the Forsaken exotics we will
see what he has and it's not a guarantee
has the possibility does not guarantee
it now the faded in gram does not have a
chance for forsaken exotics will be
updated in a future patch I'm like
really yeah I know I know it's like
really were this for six months from
forsaken or 7 and you still can't like
at least guarantee something that you're
missing since it's been this long in the
making I don't know I don't know what
future patch it's gonna be but if
they're wailed all the way till season
of opulence I'm gonna be like really
well someone that actually drops but at
least szura has a chance of them coming
through so I'll be making my video at
11:00 I mean Ben II he's so hyped for so
today he's hoping for the Wolves ax I
don't know if uh do you think Laurel
wolves can come from xur because I feel
like it's tied to spider I feel like
that one specifically is I think you're
gonna need to go through the spider
boundaries to get at that one because
that's specifically where it drops from
I think the general world ones that are
not bounty tied are ones that I would
definitely say should be in there now
but that one I think is like what you
said spider related whole before is I
need I need me some geo max it's time
it's time it's time I did do I've been
they give me Phoenix protocol I won't be
mad
Phoenix is pretty good what I eat me
some mags man I need the mags I need to
experience that that Dragon Ball Z does
he know what I'm talking about I'm never
experienced you know let's do that but a
shout-out to uh real quick that new
exotic though do mags might be in
trouble trouble for the you storm
barrels out there man because um that I
don't know if you've seen it uh II have
you seen get away artist I literally
haven't seen any other new exotic so we
look it up real quick because now I've
gotta know what the heck this thing does
alright all my store break might be time
to dust off storm call a man this thing
basically is an inert original reading
the description right now I'm like okay
I'm gonna tell me what this is so it is
an amped-up sinister has it's an
amped-up version of the ark soul so
basically you charge your grenade like
you eat the grenade then in stay it
aggressively hunts things that you can't
see last for twenty seconds then when
you use your rift if you're using bottom
class stormcaller
fresh the town rate this thing is a
beast in PvP it's a it does substantial
I mean this decent damage man it is
really a yeah shout it is you could
actually use it with chaos reach too
because being that you want your grenade
a lot to get it to activate the would
chaos reach how you get the little ionic
traces back yeah yo it is a top tier
storm call
or you know lightning class exotic so
what all those grenade mods and put them
all over your honor
put your grenade mods on give me this
thing it is an amped-up turret version
of the ark soul he's like your little
buddy he lasts a long time he's much
stronger than the standard ark so yeah
big the exotic exotic intrinsic perk is
dynamic duo pulled to convert your art
grenade into a supercharged art soul
that functions as an autonomous turret
and I'm just reading that I'm like what
is happening right now oh shut up Dale
your chat I will get your IC cities that
got it
like I was so jealous and we were in the
crucible and it's literally like he's
he's now he's like one of the two
tablets and the damn get away artists is
hunting them down and it's it's
ridiculous and killing people yes
everywhere you go and it does fairly
good damage in PvE to me it's really
it's a good idea to get away if you're
in the middle of like the reckoning with
that thing it's just gonna probably be
going nonstop I'm just thinking about
four or five warlocks with it running in
trouble man that's the one class I mean
they're very two different like ones a
super like a boss melter the other one
is like enemy melter so I mean that one
paired with say like a reaper build for
a new prime would be just start killing
ads like go to town mmm-hmm it's really
good yeah so that's that's kind of cool
I like how that I like how that really
changes like articles like pew pew pew
like this actually changes it to be like
that's a build like that's what more
exotics need to be getting to like make
it a build this looks fun
so I've deal in my chat right now shout
out in good morning who doesn't want a
little aggressive Ark soul buddy yep
gotta have it
so some black armory fixes things like
that were talked about they're finally
out there and done
let's see some general fixes we're done
as well
needs of light rain of things out there
I'm not going to go through all the
fixes there
fix fix fix yeah you guys can look at
those if you so desire go to bungie.net
read the patch notes they'll be in
descriptions and such yeah
oh let's see activities hosted by the
drifter have been moved to a it's owned
gambit and submenu so I figured that was
gonna happen so finally did actually
change it up mmm-hmm
gambits blocker changes have changed so
we got the Goblin now the captain and
the Knights well kind of get into these
when we start our game a prime
discussion because I want that to be
just a separate thing absolutely um had
you play any normal gambit this season
though before we get in again did you
get a sudden-death round uh I'm gonna
say no I did how was it how was it
I mean portals instantly open and bosses
up and just good yeah it's fat like it's
it does speed that along but I think as
we were talking about in DCP last night
it was saying like like gambit should
just be one around I mean that just
feels how it should be there's Jimmu
primes its own thing and I like some
changes and stuff to it but three like
even two plus it's still a long time you
know but it does shorten it up so you
don't have to go through another 10
minute round for round three so it is
definitely better that way okay okay
yeah yeah basically says the Prime Evils
immediately summoned players supers
grenades ability melee are immediately
filled so both teams are an even playing
field so literally like clean slates
everybody super grenade ability and
melee region are increased for the
remainder of the round so you are not
quite mayhem mode it's not that level
but it's like invasion burns like it's
gonna be hardcore quick it's like you
shout out the shadow kid he's talking
about get away honest he says all dark
soul throwing marshmallow new art soul
throws coffee table full of bricks
I gotta get get away artists man Oh
gonna be thinking about it all day you
guys started well if it's anything like
the Forsaken exotics I would not hold
your breath you will not make it till
next week
I know good to you let's see gambit
matchmaking teams are now always broken
up when re-entering matchmaking pool
after a match that's good I still wish
there was more of a solo queue cuz I
mean
been talking yesterday and forget if it
was I think holes he's like soul acute
once mm-hmm you know then got with one
person it's like and then just as soon
as he had like actual a stacked four
puts four stack he's like we were just
stomp stomp stomp stomp and it was just
like going against solos and it's
there's a point where that has to get
looked at I mean I know they're worried
about matchmaking times and things like
that but honestly like the matchmaking
times have their ups and downs anyway
and if it was a minute longer but I play
like a you know a fairly more mixed
version of like who I'm going against it
would be better cuz when I'm going
against if I'm getting like worked and I
pull up the you know the roster to see
who's in the match and it's if it's a
four stack with the little you know
giant white bracket outside the forum
like of course we're losing like and
that's not and it doesn't ever surprise
me but then it's like then it's
defeating me like well I guess I got to
play through this one and see what
happens
I've probably pulled it out a few times
here there where I just get some great
invasions my team gets their act
together but generally that four stacked
in especially with game a prime there's
some things you got to know and if they
don't it's brutal like yeah or sex it's
even more important yeah are you guys
talking about on DCP and I completely
agree there's still some yeah I complete
literally what exactly what you said
there's also strategies with and we'll
get into that yeah yeah gambit HUD
infamy triumph some medals like changes
and stuff like that so they did increase
the infamy reward points for game it
matches by 25 so boosting your infamy
speed because we're going to like 15,000
points so thanks a little while a whole
bunch of fixes the fixes and stuff like
that we know the prismatic matrix is
gone we knew that was coming
what did you think of the bundles and
stuff like that from mom ever yeah from
TAS I think we briefly touched on it
last the last time brought oh yes like
unless I like my little present
prismatic I'm not gonna lie do miss them
I'm saying I used to go there you get
kind of roller slots but I had a more
kind of idea a focused idea of what you
could possibly get so I mean but at the
same time the other part I mean it's
just like you know look I see it's it's
you know cosmetic
really doesn't bother me you know I
don't know one thing though I want that
that Malfi that new version of that new
ornament I got had at that one looks so
good it he got the red Dino at a red
thread around like the back of the
barrel and just like the bright clean
green like engraving on it yeah that one
that's the one like one like that that's
the one I would spend the money on cuz I
think it's awesome it looks so good
soon is that they are getting that money
I don't care what nobody say so yeah
that right there in it shall okay I
don't know if we talked about I think I
talked about the Malfi Z once in a while
but um I love that gun I think it
doesn't get it I know everybody's on a
throne and last word kick but it is a
dual-purpose gun I mean I don't use it
in standard PvE activities now um I you
like gambit it's I have to run with it
now that's part of my loadout and it
destroys invoice d-stroid anyway now
Prime Evils is asking a lot but envoy's
don't even stand a chance like literally
I just went out there with mouths easy
and then an arm and crucible as a 180
it's so stable you know so yeah man I
love that gun I have to get that
ornament man hello I love what they
doing but yeah as far as tests got no
problem and I'm not complaining about
none of that stuff yep
so that pretty much covers the patch
quite a few things have changed and now
obviously what you guys have been
waiting on season of The Drifter is
actually live it's a thing so I want
your initial impressions on gambit prime
itself and just kind of understands what
do you think what do you thoughts think
it's good I mean I think it's definitely
better than standard gambit um you know
we talked about the class systems and
stuff of that nature I love that aspect
I love the specific roles right now I'm
in my century bag you know I'm guarding
up you know protecting the bank you know
and I love the new mechanic I love the
new audio cues like well tonight Oh
like it really makes you feel bad when
blockers are on the field feels like I
had to go back get them
you know on that not everything is all
peaches and cream there's some things I
don't like necessarily but I think could
be tweaked um you guys touched on it on
DCP yesterday which is um you know that
first round of the DPS phase with the
primeval we do annex like you one you
got to be very cognizant of the invader
like if the invaders on the field you
got a third and way up do not kill the
throne anyway you so many blueberries
with a plan we kept killing it then with
like the invader literally knows where
you guys are gonna set up shop to DPS
so it's like he's wiping out the whole
sky
oh yeah yeah that's the first day and
then the other thing I learned is that
like you can't really go all out in the
DPS fade the first DPS phase you said
I'm saying so what I really can't
yeah it's a little weird in that mistake
I understand they don't want you to just
instant melt like I used to in gambit
but I think I think it was teff T or um
a halt set it on DCP when I listen to
you guys which I totally agree the
problem I got right now is that if you
like the heavy is so random that like if
you don't have heavy during dps phases
or when someone's invading you're
helpless like you're really helpless man
so that's the only thing how to figure
out how to tweak that but overall the
mode is don't just set all like I said
the century to collect all those roles
that you got a screen really love it
really adds a sense to love the AMA says
the perks will get into reckoning with
the gameplay loop and um the only thing
is who in the vid och four they said
yeah it's one round and get in get out
yeah right sure yeah we you talked about
this um those matches can go really long
like really like longer than gambit you
know so that I gotta figure out how
they're gonna do but what about you what
are you feeling now that you've been in
there but where you at with a can be
Prime yeah so I mean definitely if you
guys hadn't you know didn't catch DCP
last night we covered a lot but
for me I like and hold said this Wells
like the one to a hundred moat phase
really cool like he nailed that like he
phrased that one I agree
like I like how you know to blocker
starts you losing motes it gives you a
different purpose like you hear blockers
you just be like you know I'm gonna
leave them there I'm going to wait until
we're ready to Bank and then we're going
and we'll just melt them all together
like if you are working on motes
somebody has got to get their butt back
there and clear those guys out it is a
must because if you leave them there for
a while it's like a moat every second or
two it's like a it's a pretty continual
tick so you can there for long
protip make sure you guys that are
banking don't just bank one of you guys
by yourself coordinate your banks man so
that when you put in two at the same
time on the other person's side and you
drain them that's what being sinister
and inadequate doing it's a really cool
strategy you gotta coordinate your big
obviously if no one else has anything
you got like a 10 or 15 go for it but if
there's any way you guys can coordinate
going back to the bank together it
really is effective and don't go for 15
all the guys please stop with the 15th
man but that's just me continue yeah and
I was like yeah it's like the only time
I would probably go for 15 is if you're
if the other teams already got their
primeval up basically because they're
not gonna be invading if they've used
their invasions you know you're safe
that's you know that's a decent time to
send some heavier people over the other
than that it can definitely get risky
because the way the map set up you
definitely can get farther away it feels
like from the bank and man the invaders
have plenty of places to hide I do like
the new map I will say that um what do
you think of the map yeah I like a
little moving platform in the middle
yeah that was cool I will say this that
I don't think nobody's talking about oh
maybe you know I don't know if you guys
talked about it last night
yo enemies are not a game like no no no
a little bit of arrogance like it was
regular gambit I'm throwing my face and
I'm jumping in the mix and I'm not
paying attention
I'm getting melted by enemies and I was
like whoa let me slow down and pick my
shots and take my time before I
run out there because I see moats on the
floor like those big boys they'll hurt
you man and his tour it's like every
class has something and I like that it's
almost like a whole bunch of mini bosses
running around you know I mean it's a
nice I'll of the the the ads I feel like
they they add a different dynamic you
have to respect them you can't just get
too crazy did you ever face fallen by
the way I have not I think I was
thinking about the same thing I was like
I know if a sex a lot mm-hmm
cabal happened mm-hmm I know hi have you
said bring a sword but I have not faced
fallen as regular enemies once we
haven't I haven't played as many as some
but is anybody who anybody in either
chat yeah late game bit prime and faced
against following cuz I really haven't I
played like I streamed for like nine
hours of like a variety of things on
Tuesday but I was like I didn't face him
one time and I kept waiting to see how
that was gonna go I took a point I have
not not seen them anybody chat seen any
fallen I don't know yeah so I mean when
you're going against cabal solar works
well so I mean yo shout-out to yotan by
the way putting in some work whoa the on
voice two shots and basically any pair
of those are dead and you can hit him
from a decent chunk of ways away tracks
to him home I seen him I do have
headphones okay cool I was like I just
may have had mm-hmm
yeah I haven't had fallen yeah AB deal
said he never had fallen or scorned I
don't even know if scorns an option
either
no one's an option yeah that's a good
point I don't I mean that it would seem
like it they're all in gambit so you
would think they're in there but oh man
scorned and gambit prime I haven't even
thought about that yeah because I
haven't faced him but mmm-hmm some of
those guys Airy
yeah those abominations or like beefy
snipers I'm like what is this
combination of like abilities this is
terrible those abominations when you run
across one was like why why are you a
thing why is like an ogre able to snipe
me this feels wrong I gotta put in a lot
of work and he's still putting working
there lightning quick to all dude it's
yeah it's fast
you turn around in a dreaming city and
go to the bay or any wishes that lost
sector those three out there if you're
just like moseying through me like oh
oh damn it Oh yep that guy's out there
yeah they they definitely get some work
in so it's four and we'll keep it mixing
I wonder if they're like slowly phasing
stuff out or adding it in cuz I don't
know I know fallens there because you
guys were saying you guys actually saw
it but no score and I would be I don't
know so interested so yeah like the
enemies for sure don't mess around with
them but the map like the way it's built
as ly as you said there's the dynamic
moving platform in the middle the
verticality of these feel like yeah yeah
like so you're going up on this platform
or down around here or there's enemies
actually on two tiers above you when
you're in the platform area all no it's
like opposite of where the Prime Evils
basically spawn and there's just more
areas for you if you're gonna go run
full circle
you actually have places to hide you
really do so great you can kind of flank
around and actually have a chance cuz it
felt pretty exposed before to try and do
that on most of the other maps so it's a
really good map yeah I love this new map
but now I can't wait for that believe
we're getting a second one very soon
right
yeah because I know today is tier 2 for
the reckoning which we'll get to in a
bit that starts at 11:00 and then we've
got ya the map on Tuesday with other
stuff on Tuesday which we'll get to
again in Tier three is next Friday with
desert 9 stuff so yeah well there's
stuff coming but kinda will get to some
thoughts and things so gambit prime as
we were saying it's like the first like
up to a hundred motes like that invasion
scheme time in that well like definitely
knocking him down sending over the
blockers that's really cool mm-hmm when
you get to the damaged phase of the
primeval it's so long so I mean
basically if you guys haven't done it
yet and or you're just kind of wondering
what's gonna be going on is when you
some of the primeval now instead of it
just being hey this is the center
there's two envoys when you kill them
you get a boost to damage and then it's
just sitting there
and you're working on it and just when
it stays overtime now the way it works
is there are first two sets of envoys
that are somewhat split up on the map
they're not like right next to each
other so there's a little travel
involved and the third one is usually
somewhere in the same vicinity of the
kind of side that you're on but it'll be
the third one that you break and kill
will drop and you know area of effect on
the ground of it gives you your primeval
Slayer buff mm-hmm and each full
rotation is when that gets to be more
powerful right now the only problem is
if you're playing with randoms and they
kill that one and then somebody invades
when you're trying to get some damage on
it's a completely wasted damage phase
which is a thing but honestly in the
first couple of primeval Slayer
multipliers you can't kill the boss
anyway you can only get it down to about
a third health and then on top of that
if they get like one maybe two kills the
bosses all the way back up to full and
you're like oh my god so what what do
you think about the primeval lake
because I know we talked about some
ideas and stuff last night but I mean
you may have listened or not but what do
you think about the whole phase you know
whether it's like capping damage at a
third once you get it like once you get
it down so far you might actually be
able to keep it there no probably get
like a team wipe any full heal and
you're like yeah like it so much
progress is lost it's it's disheartening
and it really extends the matches extra
long you don't say so um yeah I would
like a tweak like that because um you
know listen I don't want to penalize
invaders but I feel if Veda isn't really
dominant man like I mean it can really
and then with these perks and stuff you
know and now you're saying you know with
that first phase you can't really
there's nothing you really can do to
kill the primeval outright you can't
melt them the first one I sure yeah man
I mean it's it's tough man it's tough I
figure they got it they gotta try they
they're gonna eventually have to tweak
it on some level you're not I'm saying
definitely something because I mean I
know invasions gotta be a thing like you
get a good invasion you want to feel
like you got something out of it and
then it's just that timing of and that's
kind of the balance where I feel like it
is difficult also for Bungie to figure
it out because if you do cap it
third say get a third damaged off first
phase you time it right you let the
invasion come in then you pop the third
envoy you get a chunky give them to a
third you're locked in there and then
maybe you do like a damage cycle to kill
the envoy you don't worry too much about
the image and you get to that third or
fourth stack mm-hm and then people do
you know either ward cliff coils or you
know well of Radiance timed in with some
other stuff and you can finally like
pump some damage then you might be able
to straight-up melt it because you have
that third off already and you're not
gonna excuse me have the time to even
invade and save it right so it's like
it's this delicate balance to walk and I
don't know if it's like maybe the kills
don't give as much health back but you
can in it kind of and you maybe you get
like diminishing returns like up to that
third you maybe bump it up a little bit
but you can't like send it way back to
full you might bump in hair over or
something so you've got a little farther
some type of progressions where you
can't just like hey we got it down to
2/3
they come in wipe the whole team we
start all over because the red dude has
some health I agree man and now you're
talking multiple damage phases again
from the start which again extends the
match extra long which is what I thought
was not their goal with gambit which is
to have these super lengthy matches you
know I'm say it was supposed to that the
premise of prom was supposed to be this
one round intense balls-to-the-wall
super tension kind of deal right and it
can be that if circumstances work
perfectly right Breanna is there's gonna
be clutch invasions they're gonna be you
know multiple phases and even if you
don't you know this I've seen times when
I get down to the third phase and then
you don't gambit white but you go all
the way back to the beginning again so
it's literally the reset of the whole
game you know I'm saying and I'm on both
sides I'm just like man I've been in
this match so long like it's really you
know for the sense for the sake of speed
you know they really really might have
to tweak and I think you're onto
something which is you know diminishing
returns that could only be a certain
amount after a certain time so that
there's not that official reset button
well that's also the idea of I mean if
you
it takes away from roles like reaper
more collector for having real purposes
because the invasion is so strong if
they come in and you get to invade all
the time so if you've your primeval up
first you're at a disadvantage because
they're still sending blockers over
you're not gonna lose the primeval spawn
but you have to manage those managing
the on voice and you have invader coming
over every 30 45 seconds or whatever the
time is and you're not able to really as
if they're invaders decent they don't
have to spawn first and you have a
harder time getting damage done because
the blockers just keep coming well
they're trying to catch up to you
you can't invade them to slow them down
and that's it's like this tough cycle
like I was ahead I don't know we walked
one team to get to the perennial phase
it was like a hundred max of 40 like we
were way ahead they came back and beat
us mm-hmm and had that much time to go
through it now it'd be different if like
you know they get ahead but they start
invading but it's still an invasion you
should be able to get those stacks a
little sooner and again that's where
coordinated teams could probably manage
that a little better with the stack
ahead of the other team
yes but generally like if you are that
part you're like okay we whooped him oh
I had an awesome invasion I took 50
notes from a guy we had the blockers on
the bank they really had some struggles
I mean we just like you know stepped on
him for a while
for them to even come back and be that
close kind of defeats the other part of
like the fun of the initial part of
gambit mm-hmm and I don't and I don't
know how to fix that I'm with you I
think you got it I think what you said
and you know again there can only be
health up to a certain point you can't
max health so that you know if the
invaders getting kills yeah it'll get
the prime mover up but not all the way
back to hundred percent maybe he goes to
a then each of each subsequent round
it's like you know a little less that
kind of thing so yeah I think they have
to do that is it's just it's very
demoralizing you know multiple times
doing multiple phases yeah so it's like
they're it's it's I like the changes to
a lot of the mode like the hundred
months feels good the one mode like the
three sets of envoys for the actual
damage phase you kind of gotta move
around it's not it was just gonna be a
the bosses on the platform let's kill
the envoys meltem like it's not going to
be that there's some mobility
you gotta move around and it gives a
little randomness to where the
encounters are gonna take place like if
you're on the to close ones to the boss
you can probably do a work cliff coil
but if you're the one across the moving
platform or cliff coil it probably
doesn't have the accuracy to do that
type of melt so even that positioning
can change strategy per what round
you're on so I mean that stuff is cool I
like the like moats draining because
that actually gives login incentive
that's one of the coolest things man
that doesn't stand up to the blockers
themselves yeah and also that also means
like if you invade with that full
invader set you have to go push on them
because they're gonna stand next to the
bank and just drain it all on their own
and you can't just hide love it and
again I know we had concerns last week
about the weakening of certain blockers
but now that they've added that mechanic
it really doesn't matter because your
stats alone trains the bank so two
drains abate and like I say it's a cool
mechanic man like I said we we've come
back by doing a lot of those you know
two and three blocker deposits at one
time and it can it's damaging man cuz
again your natural reaction based on
playing old gambit is to just go out
search the field get much get much get
moans no one's really paying attention
to the bank it doesn't but when you hear
that along and yellow that you like
brother and that stuff starts draining
faster mm-hmm it adds a danger mechanic
that I really like that to me is one of
the best new additions of prom love it
yeah so I mean it's it's interesting so
this is part one of season of directors
game to prime some tweaks are some
adjustments I guess we'll say we'll see
kind of how things progresses people
give better sets and just start stepping
on people more which will be a thing but
the other side is the reckoning mm-hmm
how much reckoning have you played um
that was interesting cuz though I didn't
know what to expect
you know if you do the wager mechanic
yadda yadda yadda you know um I will say
this lore wise as much as I complain
about them
I actually like them working with the
drifter in this conjunction gambit slash
hoard you know
rinse and repeat kind of they're both
connected both activities right you play
prime you know to get the sense and all
that and then you deposit the sense in
reckoning and then you kind of wager and
then you go inside you know and try to
get the gear and it survived so yeah I
mean it's it's it's brutal because
you've got those taking snipers up top
everyone's spawning everywhere you don't
really feel safe you know as far as
hiding and stuff like that you know when
I went in there a couple of times they
had the rotating you know burn mechanic
with the polarization
have you gotten that one like it was
void sans prism the rotating yeah that's
how is that it does it rotate every day
because I only play it I think on
Tuesday honestly because I've been
working I played man I think I played
what day I play I was rotating and
another day I played I was like wait a
minute there's no rotating feature so I
don't know I gotta look at like how that
works specifically but I've seen it
without it as well you know means so on
but no I do like it
and we a shout out to shadow can
question in the trailer where that was
in a cutscene does anyone get no I
didn't get a cutscene on that either I
was I thought we would get that with
with the drifter in the mine so maybe
they're saving it for later on during
the season but um yeah back to the mode
the modus is is fun it's hard you know
taking definitely are annoying
um it's decent it's not nothing like oh
my god this is the craziest thing I've
ever seen
I would probably rank it still
escalation protocol is still about baby
like one of my favorites as far as like
those type of moans so I wouldn't put it
there but it's like in the middle it's
better than flying well you know saying
it's more engaging in that and um yeah
is you know I'm with it I'm with it man
I'm what I like it I want to see only
thing negative I will say though it was
kind of discouraging to get that low
gear like the low light gets like 6:30
or like like that was like a you know
Sam Blake yeah what were you a Twitter
tell me about we get with the recommend
so I mean this is the part that I was
hoping for obviously being more PvE I'll
I
how they have modifiers on it I actually
didn't expect that which was good it
seems like the singe is going to be
probably the week and then somebody said
like attrition was yesterday and then I
know the first day was prison like the
rotating buff so it looks like they may
be rotating through D buffs and stuff
like that so that's actually kind of
cool that's gonna kind of change every
day we always joked about having like
modifiers and raids and this is kind of
there's gonna be a pinnacle version of
this like the tier 3 is gonna be brutal
so playing this on the right day
definitely might be a thing because some
of those are going to be harder than
others so the wagering of the mote is
doesn't have the weight that I thought
it would because when it says Oh way to
remote but then I was like I somebody in
one of my comments was saying oh you can
get it back even if you die like I'm
like well then where's the where's the
stress to like survive and work together
and hopefully not die it's just like
well if I don't I'll just stay in here
and do it again like I do like that you
can stay in there yeah now I wish that
you didn't have to have a synth to go in
there yeah I guess if I didn't want to
go play game but crime but I want to go
do reckoning practice or go help some
friends but I don't want to know do a
game of prime match first and I just
wish that requirement wasn't on there I
mean I understand you want to bank but
you don't have to bank and you can still
go jump in because I honestly was like I
jumped in with like three and a half
minutes I was like well I have no idea
how long this timer is I'm just gonna
jump in and play and for a wager my
first one we did it eventually and then
it went but hmm
just the wagering we only get two you're
one right now you are as we're getting
six thirty drops I was like mmm do you
think Abby asked you a question do you
think as we go to tier 2 to tier 2 is
today right yes right so as we go to
tier 2 or tier 3 do you think that the
waves your mechanic will actually hold
weight and you won't get it maybe this
is kind of like to set up the
introduction with tier 1 so it'd be a
nice as far as giving it back I mean
that would be a weird inconsistency
thing if they did it that way because
you would establish that you know oh if
I Bank and I fail I get it back so if
you you know wager the two which is now
gonna be more expensive for an attempt
and then it says no then if there's not
a pop-up warning or anything that says
you know if you if not you know if not
completed
we'll lose these modes like are you sure
like if that's not popped up like once
are any explanation to like tier 2 being
different then I think that's poorly
done if it's not a consistent message I
mean I wouldn't mind it gives it more
weight definitely make make sure like
hey I might want to have a couple
friends on but it is matchmaking I think
the level for this one's gonna be like
670 so it's definitely jumping pretty
quick and then tier 3 is supposed to be
kind of in-game 690 stuff for sure
multiple phases on tier 2 tier 3 is
probably gonna have even more and
mechanics it looks like you have in the
little video thing that they did which
we're not gonna watch but the video
about the reckoning they show tier 3
they show the Knights that go smashing
around and doing everything those guys
are always terrifying mm-hmm
so I'm guessing those are in tier 3 it
looks like we've got this bridge into
your two with like the ogres and so yeah
we're gonna have to like do the first
phase that made me cross the bridge for
tier two and maybe you have to get
inside the cavern like the dark space
that we see in the trailer interior yeah
maybe my hunch how that goes I don't
know mm-hmm I agree I think there might
be some some truth to that maybe it's
all did you know through it with each
tier but yeah it is taking enemies like
all the time mm-hmm what are your
thoughts on like pretty much I know
about Verta there are taking war beast
that's like they did one new enemy I'm
like kinda I sort of beat bowling yeah
yeah the meat ball was in there as one
of the bosses I saw him I saw one that
looks like dracky on from the pyramidion
yeah like the big and he's a sniper boss
so he definitely is one to watch can
hurt they got decent boss rotation in
there so I sent area and stuff like that
but they're all just taken which right
you know take or leave it but taken
sometimes has its annoyances oh yeah big
time
big dope yeah I mean let me tell you
right now I'm if you guys haven't been
running any rate you need to run that
last with all that taking armaments whew
luckily I got one man oh my my class
item getting that heavy in there so much
feels so good oh so such an important
little little thing so taking armament
mods if you got them this is the this is
the place to use them really good
but yeah I mean it's cool to me I mean
I'm not like again I'm not wowed but I'm
not like upset like oh this mode is not
you know it's tough you got to work oh
you know what I like I like the fact
that you got a revive your friends oh
yeah not going there thinking that you
just gonna try to solo stuff because
that time that you're wasting enduring
the dominant domination phase dominance
phase whatever they call it like you've
got to be coordinated you can't like
it's a little tough for sometimes that
people are not paying attention and
you're playing with blueberries that I
just weren't about what DPS they're
doing cuz you need everybody it's about
speed you know I'm saying and you got to
get that that dominance meter thing up
so you can start spawning more stuff out
so that that mechanic I actually like
about it because it adds a little bit
more attention to it but again it's it's
right in the middle for me I don't have
it above escalation protocol probably
right below but it's definitely not a
blind well you know trash kind of mode
that I don't like but where do you rank
it where you haven't it uh I mean it's
alright I'll be curious how the
challenges get on tier two and Tier
three is right now it's kind of walk in
and work it so yeah um not really that
big of a deal no it's you know fairly
reasonable mode I wasn't sure and then
when you kind of figure out just you
need to start killing stuff taking on
the big boys and then get the boss in
there and you seem to have plenty of
time to melt the boss he's not really
too hard so they did make it accessible
on day 1 day 1 which is kind of a good
thing for that loop to get you going
but then on in turn unfortunately we get
to the side of like the armor sets like
what is the whole point of this loop and
this is what we were talking about
yesterday on DCP and it's the loop of
play game but prime for the sense that
you get from either doing bounties or
doing activities and shout out to
invasion sense because those just seem
to come quicker because I made it more
often
collectors seem to be like impossible to
get then you take a sense you put them
in the wager bank in the reckoning you
go to your activity you get a piece of
gambit gear that is unless it's a weekly
bounty is gonna be 20 points lower just
like a random in gram mm-hmm so you're
gonna have to get some infusion in there
infusion still not be still having you
know enhancement cores
that kind of takes away the instant news
because when you go into gambit you've
got PV like power level actually
mattering on invasions or being invaded
mm-hmm I'm just adding all this stuff on
and then on top of that the sets that
you get are only useful in gambit rhyme
not even just gambit gambit prime only
hmm no you're right no like if you love
gambit prime sweep this is gonna be an
awesome loop for you
if gambits really not your thing then
the whole armor set like grind is kind
of not so much yeah before we even get
into like all the like skills and
talking about those like I mean I know I
basically sound like I built that thing
up and just chopped it up flags like
what are you I mean what are your honest
thoughts about that loop because for me
I have some frustrations with it it's
like I understand this one is like
gambit prime you know has some lore or
you know some reasons to it but like I
don't know what do you think it's a
tough one because this is kind of new
territory for them in a sense of them
trying to link two separate activities
that are required or based on each other
right so um you know I mean listen I it
does suck that when I start the
reckoning I'm the gambit gear really
it's not doing anything for me the game
of pride right so I'm just a little
frustrated because I want to really rock
that gear and I know it's not gonna have
you know the purchase stuff but it just
seems a little weird arm to your point
you know you've got some valid you got
some valid points day I mean it's I just
have to see the reason why I'm gonna be
on my on my poke their hat on right now
I've got to see more before I declare
this some type of broken mechanic I
wanna see where they go I want to see
once tier 3 you know what happens what
are we getting what do we do you know
maybe there is something that reveals
itself as we get to the tier 3 right
because the vibe I'm getting from you
ease day you really struggling with
reckoning more or just well it's the
it's the loop of both like thee
I like gambit prime is a different
play gambit and its thing and then
reckoning housing the rewards and
reckoning as the main purpose is these
armored sets but I can't take him into
night falls I can't take him a strike I
can take when I raise patrols they're
just random gear like anything else and
say I don't get like you know ok machine
gunner serves or you know fusion rifle
scavenger or a perk up got on it there's
no reason for me to take it in to
anything else it's just a random roll of
armor at that point that looks different
because it glows but other than that it
serves me no purpose outside of
literally one bubble on the director
that's it
oh jeez so it's a very very specialized
yeah and this is kind of the point of ok
for one you have four different sets for
three different characters
welcome to vault space hell which I
already deal with on a daily basis
doesn't work yes like I am anybody who
watched my straighten the other Bertil
and it's wrong I know but mm-hmm that's
a thing for even people who have some
stuff and they you're like ok now I'm
about to have so let's see three
characters four sets of armor five
pieces of gear do the math on that real
fast like three for 12 it's you know
that's like 37 pieces a year like you're
talking about a lot of crap so it's a
lot to hold on to yes
and it's just it it's still for one mood
and that's kind of the only annoyance is
that I understand the perks are
specifically for that hey if there's a
raid set it's that but it's like this is
and this is where I think it's more of
more testing more let's see how this
goes let's see how we can iron out the
functionality of a set in a certain
place because sets for everywhere like
where's a vanguard set that helps me in
strikes and story controls where's my
raid set that gives me you know like if
it's not a Reaper set it's the last wish
plus bonuses or whatever and you can get
some increased benefits to those and the
worst part is they brought it up
yesterday and actually I hadn't thought
about it that way you shouldn't honestly
be getting any of this stuff right now
you should be saving your sense because
yes you're going to eventually want to
just go for the tier 3 those are gonna
cost three cents instead of one so
really the point in this level
one in level to gear is next and nothing
mm-hmm because sadly you're not gonna do
much with it I hate what you saying I'm
as you're good there's not like a node
that says upgrade this initial piece of
armor I have different names you can't
make a different mode you wager it for
tier two and then you're gonna get that
tier two so it's literally like put tier
1 and tier 2 I mean I forget which one
said it last night well there's teff to
your Pope or Breyer or you know five
five six five thousand or hold I'm
talking like six people it's like I
don't know said it just power level I
think was Breyer was like the one in
that instance was like just literally
level do your powerful engrams work on
leveling up spend your time doing that
if you're gonna raid you know get some
of those taken taking mods and stuff
from last wish but then again you turn
around and you go back to the same thing
we went to in season of the forge and
going back to the same content we've
been grinding and it feels slow as hell
yeah is that everything on the director
is one health one level it's like oh
yeah is disgusting let's get in this
like I played it for bit I did a couple
of powerful you know drops powerful gear
activities and it's giving me plus one
and I'm like wait a minute what's going
on like I literally was just mantling
stuff I was just like you know these dad
that does not feel good like you doing
powerful activity and you point and then
a point that tells me that I have to
agree the problem with the annual pass
format
mm-hm is that but prior DLC say what you
want about curse of Osiris or war mind
or what-have-you but when those DLC
started you felt the destiny world had
changed right you felt that was the
problem with these annual passes this is
like very pocket based like you don't
know the black armory is a pocket based
thing and then when you're playing it
you still got to do dreaming city all
this other stuff the same stuff you've
been doing right now granted I'm in
order to level up right like it's not
that you're just doing nothing but war
mine I mean black black armory stuff
exclusively you're not doing nothing but
gamer prime stuff exclusive
you still gotta play this other stuff so
the old DLCs it was one of those things
where the world change you notice
differences you have more power source
more vendor refreshes things changed as
a whole the Annual Pass seems like it's
so pocketed in these little corners and
that I have a problem cuz it's like
we're still going back to doing the old
things that we got to do you know I'm
saying just to level up as opposed to
just staying in this new content yeah I
mean it's one of those points where if
I'm gonna be doing powerful gear and
drops like make the directors be like
two or three so I start feeling but make
those priming grams higher god forbid we
get up to 700 like they're worried about
tight the main reason they're doing this
is because they want tier 1 and tier 2
and tier 3 to not be farmed but you
literally go look up on destiny tracker
like the highest level in two days by
the way which is just bananas cuz I feel
like my light levels like 650 mm-hmm so
my Titan I played a decent amount not a
ton I played mostly Tuesday I haven't
played as much and I got the 656 I got
some some moles yeah I didn't go run
both raids on all three characters
people are 686 today wow wow wow I mean
what a raid in they gotta be rated right
yeah so I mean but you see like you know
the top 30 people or 680 and above so I
mean you take an activity that's 690 and
you just took the challenge out of it
cuz they can still grind so their whole
worry about time gating pieces of like
hey we don't want you to be too high
level so this reckoning Tier three isn't
too easy right for the people who know
life it anyway yeah is e 686 I'm going I
don't even I don't understand
it's got somebody some new hustle man I
mean we know crowning grams are
definitely yeah I mean that's that's a
thing as Prime's but I mean you'd have
to do like molt like all like both raids
on every character you'd be doing a
hundred thousand point nightfall which
at 680 you probably could start doing
every piece of gear and there's some
orangey to make sure you got like all
your slots continually getting filled
but like I mean not ever and this is
again further not everybody and this is
also kind of a
is because save for the people who do
know life it didn't they get these Tier
three sets that we're talking about
they're the ones that actually have the
really good perks to we'll get to in a
second because apparently this is gonna
be hashtag long point yes sir um because
it's already been a minute
mm-hmm they're gonna have those they're
gonna start stomping people and game at
prime even more and then you're like oh
my god like so yeah
the people who casually come in a solo
person at no level you know no new gear
stuff and they see somebody glowing in
red mopping the floor with them standing
by a bank absolutely destroying their
team and then their higher level and
then they melt it and they can't touch
it's just like it's this continual thing
and I'm just going there's there's an
issue there yeah I mean and then we got
a you know child the filly who's making
some points as far as light level you
know I wanted to kind of compound now
only from the standpoint of besides that
you still have the enhancement core
issue which is preventing you from
jumping up the way you want to jump up
that's still you know a lot of people
feel strongly about it and a lot of
people feel that it's inherently just
something to slow you down and time
gauge you and when I see to me let's get
let's call it how I see it
since the annual pass structure has been
released everything is to hold you at
bay until this week and then that
weekend though you know say like it's
it's this force holding kind of deal and
I don't know how I really feel about
that you know that like it you just want
to kind of do what you want to do and
not feel like you gotta wait till next
week for this and wakeful next it's you
know the drip-feed content is okay to an
extent
I don't mind it with the lore stuff I
didn't mind it you know find out about
ocean and all that stuff that was cool
for lore but like I don't know man it's
just you know I don't know necessarily
how I feel long term with this annual
past structure it's not the worst thing
I've ever played I'm not saying oh my
god is too well you know this is cursor
Osiris level or this is like you know
whatever
crota but you know it's just the time
gaining and definitely enhancement cause
definitely mass work that's another
annoyance where it's just like oh
yeah I mean and that's the thing you're
gonna give me all this new gambit prime
armor at 6:30 how many you know not
everybody's a hoarder of enhancement
cores like okay four sets of armor and
you're gonna be able to get all of those
you know like hey let me test him out
and see which I make myself six thirty
instead of six fifty I'm weaker against
invaders and everything it's like it
sucks and what which which then goes
into this whole thing again shot the
Philly Eagle which is they really need
transmog right because then I gotta look
ugly where stuff what perks that are not
synergized just because the light level
is higher just because in order to order
for me to do harder content and like I
got stuff sitting in my damn I really
don't want to wear this because I have
to you know I don't want to infuse this
cuz I need this it's just too many of
this unnecessary decisions that
shouldn't this should interfere with the
you know the light process and I don't
know how they're gonna they're Hamlet
man I think they're so worried about
people power leveling but as we see with
their 686 is running around right now
people are still finding a way to get
around I still struggle with and you'll
pass structure right now yeah I'm with
you so I'm trying to figure out
something with work so it's a little
distracted in the text I can run my
mouth if you needed yeah no it's like
just one of them things where just like
shot the dizzy said I feel at a time I
get the cords ready then I got to get
ready for a level boosters fax that's
like that is literally the issue because
again not everybody is running around
with a whole bunch of enhancement cause
and they're still not readily available
yeah they kind of help with a scrapper
brownies a little you know you get one
here and there you get gonna break down
it needs to be a guaranteed source
give me an activity you know I'm saying
5000 shards let me buy a few of them
that's what I'm saying can we get like
somebody useful like let can we give
brother Vance can we give her a job
could someone have
can I stop going this spider and he keep
doubling the price of the brick out here
like he ever tell you I got him for 10
but if you give me some now flip it and
they'll be 20 and it'll be 40 and hey
I'm tired of this drug exchange I got a
deal with this man cuz he would hustle
me every time I go to the tango show
just yeah buy that one okay now it's
more expensive we got that demand just
went up yeah just went up man go to
brightly one side these cars going up
you know I'll give you 40 40 shot at 80
shots now you know and you got to wait
to the reset tomorrow like come on man
like it's such a is such a time gated
which I don't want you to get these cars
that you need for leveling it's funny
yeah I know and that's that's a design
philosophy you know they've like thought
about it because I've seen people either
cosmo taking feedback about it and it's
a huge thing is the enhancement courses
my brother hates it and i totally
understand it it's another thing like
that's they really want to grind up to
700 doing more of the same stuff and
it's don't make it as big of a deal on
the power level stuff let us like infuse
for nothing because god forbid people
get to high level content and dizzy set
it in your chat it's like no or filial
did it's like that's a major issue when
the light level shouldn't make content
easy mm-hmm and that's like that's a
major flaw that destiny has had for a
lot of this stuff is the forge was
harder at first but now it's basically a
joke once you're high enough level oh my
the attic goes out of control
you see y'all go had to wrap this up I
reserved a date with law Cognito for
destiny i delay this bed is pc try to
get his grind on try to end the podcast
continue but yeah that's it's it's a
it's a issue that seems to be a parent
right now and it's one of those things
that we have to wonder what is going on
and we've talked about it multiple times
what is d3 what a September hold is it
or is there a wait is there this like is
there a point of like is taking the
focus away from d2 to put on d3 like
sacrificing some content here are their
decisions they're even making are they
good holding us off I mean let's just
call me date yeah it's like so it's like
and then the question is like when do
you think it'll be ready it's like you
know it's been in the works but for them
to do it right and well like they're
gonna be looking at some bigger changes
again which probably needs some testing
some people flying out there or to make
sure they don't butcher like a d2 year
launch to just ruin everything again
yeah so there's just so much up in the
air it's like I don't mind the
activities and you know mix it up in
gambit but even it's like it was either
briars ft were saying it's like gambits
one of those things I'm not just gonna
know life right right and we are gonna
have coming up on Tuesday we're gonna
have the vigil the allegiance quest
starting where you got a pick gambit or
some like my saison Paula but the
Vanguard but you got to decide if you're
gonna support the Zavala basically in
that feel like I core gets the shaft
because yeah so I was like it's a bad
kind of mix that you got a screw one to
not like the other but yeah I'll do
drifter on one character I mean if you
have multiple characters that's good and
if you have the annual past and hey
honestly just use the 640 power boost
and go do the other quest like you
should see them both because I'll be
interesting what that has yeah the
bounties of the 9 I'm intrigued about
those those are kind of interesting if
there's any story or lore or hearing
very excited about that action just to
explain just a smidgen of any
information about that is a good thing
mm-hm
but just this like gambit prime very
focused single armor set loop nothing
else and I even said it yesterday was
like take some of the nightfall
exclusives I'm not saying it's easy to
make a weapon but me and go put
something else in there for me to grind
because there's certain strikes I'm like
yeah if you have your duty bound you got
your you know Sabbath in song auto rifle
that thing doesn't even have random
roles on it yeah the strike exclusives
for many of the strikes outside of a few
don't have random roles why are sorry to
cut you but yeah why I've been updated I
mean that's what even ft was saying it's
like give us a more year one loot I'm
gonna bring
back to Holtzman's points of like you're
still grinding the same stuff over and
over but at least it might have a little
bit of a refresh to it like give me a
man an inane that has random roles
absolutely the assets are there they
literally sitting on all these assets
and armor pieces and weapons that they
introduced that they just not using so
again the vibe I'm getting again I'm
making excuses for it it's just that you
know this content is to hold us off
during this whole transition and then
we'll see if anything does prep for
September or you know they say hey you
know they're going all out for d3 but
yeah I agree I agree I really there's
new weapons on armor there's one exotic
that I've heard of at least and then
there's what three armor pieces yeah so
I mean you got a few to grind for the
random this time they're not actually
from the activities because game itself
doesn't really work that way and you got
some that look kind of cool I think
somebody was saying the hand cans like
150 so somebody's intrigued about
getting that one and each one of these
weapons specifically has a specific part
to it
yep so those are also a thing but like
okay so you're going for some random
drops I got the curated shotgun I think
yeah okay so I'm trying to see what the
new hold on shotgun Last Man Standing so
for mine perk on it was actually nothing
special
I know one of them for sure like I think
it was like the hand cannon or one of
these things had actually a cool perk on
it and some of these had new perks yeah
so we've got overflow picking up special
a heavy ammo reloads this weapon to
beyond normal capacity and it's a hand
cannon okay oh okay and it's got
explosive payload so while it may not be
the best it's actually got the chance to
have that in there you've got four times
the charm on this hand cannon mm-hmm so
that's you know landing precision hits
or turn to rounds to the mag you got
substance which is a new perk kills
partially reload the magazine from
reserves but reserve capacity is reduced
mm-hmm
that's kind of a trade-off of like
continually being able to do more but
you give up your reserves well you got
rapid hit and threat detector and field
prep and I don't think oh you got multi
kill clip reloading grants increased
damage based on the number of rapid
kills made beforehand so I mean and then
you got swashbuckler this weapon gains
increased damage from melee kills and
kills with this weapon okay so I mean
there are some new perks in there but
they're literally limited to like six
guns yeah you're not gonna start rolling
on like a new trust hand cannon or
something like that to my knowledge
they're not they're not gonna change
into the old stuff right yeah I mean
this is clear designs choices they did
kind of same thing with a black armory
right because you had exclusive perks
that you could only get from weapons in
that thing and this is this is a
direction they're going and again the
only thought process I keep reiterating
is that they are pulling us off to prep
for whether it be the full content DLC
or you know d3 you know saying and they
are sticking to this drip-feed stuff
during all the way until season of the
Optimates
and and then after that we will see but
I think they gotta go back to the old
model you know come September because
again it's a competitive space out here
you know we're gonna talk about anthem
we're going to talk about division and
you know this is cool for a week or two
in it like right now this is good for us
because we can actually play multiple
games with this structure right I mean
that's what I think Bungie just being
nice so we can get to enjoy I mean you
got division anthems out doing its ups
and downs but it's like it's continually
being supported whether it's got a lot
of stuff to fix or not they are trying
to stick with it right and then you've
also got like me I'm gonna play second
row I'm sorry thanks to have miss with
us and let's sec you know ii oh I was
like I finally figured I had to say
anything sir but like that's a Dark
Souls game that's gonna be like you know
thirty hours probably easy that's a
chunk of time that's gonna be something
I enjoy and for me I intended a play
game but prime is like yeah it's like
really you know go in do some powerful
gears see however you get it if you're
gonna raid do some of that but your
grind for tier
three or game crime if you let gamma
prime cool but the other stuff like can
wait and there's not really a rush on it
there's really not which is weird as a
destiny fan right isn't it weird yeah
like you know we play a little bit get
everything done so quickly wait for a
week here wait for a week there it I
said I mean it's an interesting strategy
we just got to see you know because like
you said old you know these other games
getting anthems gonna improve they're
gonna keep trying and they don't seem to
be giving up the devs seem to be working
very hard we're gonna talk about that
patch division we're gonna talk about
this end game we're gonna talk about
every time I'm turning on they are
telling me about some new thing that you
can do for any it's man it's a lot and
then we got all these single-player
games right you got a lot of stuff Devil
May Cry drop you know I'm saying like
it's a life look like you got some
pretty good reviews to how you pronounce
a second oh girl you know saying you got
that you know the Dark Soul fans are
gonna be you know this is interesting
that's why I it's gonna be curious what
happens you know going forward but I
mean again I don't want to trash season
it just like I'm enjoying myself don't
get me wrong but we are both seeing we
still see some flaws here in there and
um you know we just hope that as it goes
on at hopefully with season and opulence
that were getting more that we get with
each content drop we should be getting
you know what happened the new strikes
new crucible Maps cop is a mess right
now
like let's just call it worse than
consult yeah PvP is a mess right now
like there is no end game they'd already
told us we can get in trials no time
soon we don't know what like if you're a
pvp guy like me I'm just making my own
thing because you know there's sandbox
changes and I want to Tesla fleet mayhem
in there all the time so if I want to
burn off steam at some fun that's like
that I mean or and that's the thing
crucible labs is currently mostly being
unused they've tested it like two or
three times that could be something
where they even like you know just give
us an attempt it you know either rift
which it would be a nice thing to have
back for a different mode
elimination throat and crucible labs
just people hate go try it in there have
some fun mix it up like see what happens
if the 3v3 magic is there or not but all
of those things are
yeah it's just this compounding thing of
right now is the time when destiny is
not like your front and center because
if you especially if gambit isn't your
thing is no incentive to jump in
complying to your note of stuff again
and there's a lot of other stuff market
at your door in people like yeah I'm
gonna go play Division two next week or
I'm gonna go play Secor that week after
that or I'm gonna play both like
I don't have time to play 60 games at
once much less try and you know no life
something that right now is very very
limited in scope absolutely
abso yeah I mean a lack of additional
things to this annual pass whether it's
a strike whether it's you know a quest
every soft in the pops through and the
the allegiance quest I will be curious
in the nine stuff because that'll be but
that's like you're popping on Tuesday
that's not like make it my hobby right
so that's the big difference for me is
that it's no longer the continuous I
want to keep playing I want to keep
working on stuff the grind if there were
like six different armor sets maybe
that'd be a thing and yeah but not so
much so yeah great yeah I think he
mailed it but yeah we've got the armor
perks if you guys want to look at him
the cool ones for Reaper that's the one
who you basically clean clear as many
enemies as possible the big one is
defeating powerful enemies grants a
temporary surgeon Grenadier recharge
right so if you clear clear that one I
feel like that one's kind of lackluster
yeah plus three of the defeating a
high-value target marking and weakening
it as soon as I did that those guys did
drop fast cuz I went Reaper and I had a
I have a full set so those guys dropped
a little faster the loot pinata or the
you know pinata of death for special
ammo which is good this would like the
10 stack for the Reaper the most lasting
longer is more valuable than I swear
almost anything else
it's a PS super fast in crime in Maya I
mean they do in gambit as well cuz
you're like but they feel like in prime
you're like either further around the
corner and you don't realize they're
there it's just like a little less
obvious you don't see the beams all the
time yeah cuz I'm out of sight and stuff
yep so like that one I feel like if you
could I feel like if that ten one was
maybe where six was and then
six was a little more than just dropping
special ammo because I don't really tend
a run out of that I was running yotan
yeah and I don't think I was really
hurting on it if you mix up what you're
shooting you're probably okay so that
one seems lackluster to me collector for
now I want to see what a giant blocker
is I want to know what that is
eggs what do you think it would be big
ogre big ogre right because didn't they
get rid of you yeah they got rid of the
yogurt and I think that's the one that
makes sense for you know pushing people
off and kind of really having a crazy
health pool like that would be one that
could really make a difference I mean
holding on twenty mode sounds terrible
enamel but that's what I mean if you
know somebody's running that collector
set did you sacrifice your body you
throw your body in front of that bullet
like you go secret service on that guy
yeah though cuz if your moat collecting
and then you get a little over shield
you'd understand because it get a little
dicey sometime then Big O collecting and
then you know the invader comes in you
know every little bit of Sheol helps you
know oh you know drop a portion of your
motes carried on death so even if you
are in the mix and kind of doing that
stuff if you die your buddies can kind
of help some of that and then when you
bank you get some ammo back so I mean
running something like yotan you're
never gonna run up yeah that's a good
one yeah cash back that's a good part
especially if when I get my I get my
hands back on Lord of wolves I don't
know entry so multi kills grenade damage
buff against taken so this one's kind of
centuries a little weird it's very
specialized on smile baby the blockers
and stuff but you have to go get multi
kills and damage buff against taken so I
mean what but the way them like say the
way this map is set up in your bet that
if it doesn't last that long and you're
the one who's meant to kill the blockers
you're either hanging towards the middle
and trying to pick stuff off and like
doing their job but where are you gonna
get your multi kills from to get your
Buffett aka that puck like that weird so
you have to have a balance of Elvia
killing and going back like that's what
I have to do that I kill and going back
killing that won't last long enough I
guess would say so if you're up there
getting mixes and kills and it clears oh
I guess that clears wouldn't taken when
you
damage' taking component combatant so
it's not five times I guess go run with
your buddies do that and you be the lead
back if there's a guys there yeah
safe and sound standing near the baked
triggers health regeneration so I mean
if you're near the bank and you got to
take out some of those blockers you
might get some health to save yourself
to do that mm-hmm
damaging an invader marks them for you
one
I'm snitchin he over there that's my
dude there yeah he's over there like oh
I can't wait to get that that's my whole
goal with that class and then very snow
this is weird to me because it's very
specifically or is the well of light is
the well of light that the buff on the
ground or is it as well of radiance is
actually the class I mean this was just
warlocks but yeah the resilience
mobility and recovery in there so you're
basically helping like when it comes to
damage time if you have that full
century and then on top you get that
like you know combo of well of radiance
for the damage buff and some things I
really you're gonna be putting some work
in so buddy I hope it's stacks with well
radius Oh obviously just boosting your
own like stats you're you're just max
resilience mobility and recovery yes I
mean the well of radiance should give
you the over shield in the buff and the
damage because they're actually separate
so it should stack stack greeted yeah oh
that that I said when I read all these
perks I said this class is so me because
to be honest like I gave up trying to be
a moat collect because everyone's faster
to me steals all the big emotes and I
get frustrated so let me just go back to
the bank and then while yeah over there
collecting all the most I'm over there
collecting heavy me I want my heavy like
heavy ammo finder now for sure make sure
you are running that the taken thing
where you kill them with grenade and you
get stuff to drop is like a must so go
run last wish for that but that's the
other piece that kind of emphasizes how
important heavy ammo is in this game if
you get those heavy ammo drops and I'm
running with like a hundred and fifty
bullets of my machine gun go invade do
that come back pump some damage in real
quick like melt some mini ads pumped out
I mean like if I'm running with heavy
continuously which there
some matches where I really hardly was
running out I'm just running with my
machine gun is my primary yeah and
that's I mean to a point of being broken
but also like heavy ammo is so important
in this like if you're gonna run
Wardenclyffe coil and you're getting
those heavy ammo drops and you finally
have six shots and you don't kill
yourself on a rally barricade which
trust me I'm almost done
haha but you can pump out like six
Wardenclyffe coils into a boss I'm like
you know primeval Slayer like three or
four mm-hmm it's over yeah Oh heavy is
still that make or break for so many
things in this game I mean even when I
was running shadow throne if heavy ammo
dropped in my run I knew I was gonna be
okay but I'm not gonna try and shoot
like Vargas with like my pulse rifle and
try it through like a quarter of his
health doing that you know anything done
with that so that's like a problem with
heavy being so so important but like the
weight of a heavy weapon it should be
but it's just so-so in like it's a must
you have to help you have it's
inconsistent and they have to figure out
a balance cuz I agree I agree without it
it gets it's really disgusting out there
without it mm-hmm and it's like it
doesn't drop off although you all the
majors now like it used to which was at
least some consistent piece heavy ammo
seems to either be like I'm rolling in
it or I have zero it's know that or I
get none agree
invaders sorry last piece while invading
ammo slowly trickles into your kinetic
and energy weapons over time that's
actually kind of interesting so if I'm
using like a yo ton or a sniper be still
getting that ammo back like I don't know
how slowly but if it trickles while
invading you only have thirty seconds
it's not gonna be like ding ding ding
ding but if you get like three or four
more shots then you'll be okay grants
and improved invasion over shield like
are you freaking kidding me on that one
Lee you're already hard to kill that's
rough
I mean like damn dude yeah so evade is a
strong man they are super strong men
kill monger each Guardian defeated while
invading grants a temporary damage bonus
once you return to your own area
I mean if you do it in the primeval
phase and you could time all right go
invade come back stand on the primeval
Slayer buff and go work mmm
but the big one bank robber invade just
invading she walks the bank and then if
you stand near it you drain the moats
like oh dude how powerful is that how
game-changing is that just your presence
locks the bank and if you happen to be
over it
oh yeah let me go over there and drain
your baby could you imagine that a think
about if you have an invader 15 right
oh you're teammates yo to stack deposit
moles then you go over so you already
got to drain from the two blockers your
presence and if you really want to be
disgusting let's say you're a Titan you
put a Titan bubble sorry on the bank and
lit up how disgusting is that this firm
big-time sure this salt will be real
this yeah it's gonna be poor in heaven
pic and that's like I've been asking for
this type of stuff for forever so I'm
excited like this is a cool like
different sets of armor for gambit it
makes things interesting like if you run
like two and two or if you have a full
even team or you go for invaders so
everybody's just gonna go mess them up
like like we agree though Reaper is kind
of weak comparison weak yeah I like
working through here Reaper needs some
love like I mean a recharge rate to your
grenade energy okay motes lasting longer
should be literally like +3 yeah we
buffs I don't feel this is equal in
comparison no 15 Reaper all he's getting
is grenade recharge rates you know I mmm
I don't think so I mean I know your
points to go like kill the guys unless
you get like a 10-second buff where
you're throwing 10 different grenades
and you can just wipe an area but like
even if you do get that for
I mean I don't know it definitely feels
weak for sure
you know Kurt is collector has its
specialized benefits you gotta know
they're there you're gonna play your
role Terry in twenties like really risky
so I'd probably do only I'd probably run
collector only with a coordinated team
yeah defend me who can know that I'm
gonna be there who's gonna sacrifice
who's gonna defend me
because that giant blocker may be a big
deal but yet reaper reaper needs
absolutely absolutely yeah it's like
this just shows like armor sets are
possible
yes figured out a way to do it but low
to these in destiny three or whatever
the hell coming next I think this is
testbed for d3 that's sadly what all
this is is testbed for what's coming and
I'm fortunately it's really limited in
scope and that kind of hurts its use in
everything else which sucks yeah that's
that's pretty much everything for
dusting to you guys it's it is fun like
gamma prime is cool has its mix
reckoning is gonna be interesting when
you get to tier 3 it depends it's one of
those if you want to jump in do some
powerful gear slowly grind up over time
and if you want to play other games you
know he's your Tuesday doing some
powerful stuff maybe do a couple matches
see how the reckoning is going and try
some of that stuff and mix it up but I
would probably say you don't have to
rush anything right unfortunate and if
you like pulled away by other games not
a lot is gonna change because you're
unless you're one of those who raids a
ton your level is just gonna take some
time just do it over time
mmm-hmm which is a weird thing to say
about destiny it's so weird is they back
to walk away from a completely agree
yeah so but yeah that's kind of where
we're at the state a destiny to we'll
see it's like I'm intrigued with some of
the stuff coming next week that has me
more excited after this kind of first
week of new yeah or of the quests in
nine and those things will give us more
to do because I think some of those
Allegiance quests from one of the I
think hound ish was like there's 11
steps of that stuff I don't know if it's
time gated I don't know if you have to
go through it all but that's a lengthy
piece I've got like that's at least
gonna be something to do so cool story
maybe some lore in there so I'll be
curious about that yeah so that'll be
something to experience okay I'm looking
forward to the Laura Laura aspects to
Vanguard quest the allegiance quest you
know that kind of stuff
and like I say better than let's be
clear this is better than the Forge so
far just it needs an early stage yeah in
the content they on borgen's not just
broken they did some quality of life
stuff it's cool you know this is fun
we're having a good time but again we
don't want to sugarcoat the flaws are we
I'm glad we did talk about that that we
put that out and like I say getting me a
get out get what you gotta do you know
I'm saying and then we got two other
games to talk about oh yeah
so I'm to briefly touch on anthem and
basically go over some windows we have
some patch notes so they base stream
that they just got finished so Tuesday
the patch is supposed to hit for what
they talked about here and they also
discuss some other things that are in
the works so for the patch on March 12th
lots of crash fixes including the one
that's shedding at the shutting down of
ps4s by hours saying that no ps4s have
been permanently their issue which some
have claimed but the shut up problem
should be fixed now it should not have
happened in the first place my mother
was telling me during the the demo or
the beta when he played it with his my
nephew slay he sounded like he was
getting audio glitches because the damn
thing was so hot yes game especially I
don't like the low consoles is is rough
for sure
so that thing and ps4 is taken taking
the heat on this one of like we
struggling over here just to turn on so
that is a major major issue it's like
whether I have fun in the game or not on
PC and I've had an unpleasant run at it
this thing I said wow I was way if you
have like oh it's for my on PC cuz I
have like I have like a butt ton of fans
in my regular and I can keep a cold but
a standard PlayStation that this game
still comes out on on edition you pre
you beta test of the game for a week you
got it a one patch and then you've got
like your ps4 trying to take off and
then just melt in your lap like you know
all over they're literally crying on
their PS
we're just trying to cool it off right
now okay good problem and I'm like I
mean you've heard me talk about it I
enjoy like the foundation of anthem but
I haven't actually been as push to play
it this week cuz honestly between work
and yeah but and other things I've been
trying some other stuff I know it's
gonna be there but the way they are
working on fixing things it's one of
those that you know if I give my like
hey what's anthem light like after two
or three weeks I'm gonna be like give it
another month maybe like see where
things are stacking in May or wait for
weights like mid April and then you know
see what the new strongholds like see if
they kind of tweak some of the drops see
if the gear gets a little more variety
and then when the cataclysms when we get
a little more information what's that
that might be your time to jump in you
know burn down I come back consistent
yeah and that's a way to see how things
are with these patches in effect but
let's go down a list real quick quick
Iran so there was something saying like
a level one weapon was outperforming
in-game of some blood for like damage
numbers weren't showing right so that
was just bizarre that somebody had it to
test 30-second reach now this is big the
30-second response I mean it's like
that's just quality of life that had to
happen in you I mean the nightfall you
can't rez for certain reasons coz but I
mean you eventually can get back up
there and everyone in a group activity
especially match made random people
which are doing you have to be able to
get back in at some point a downstairs
like some gravity to death is fine but
yeah I got to get back in the fight at
some point I can't sit there and wait
five minutes for people to ever have a
chance yes I was horrible flaw that I'm
glad is on this list alright what else
so you want you'll be able to launch
missions anywhere in for Tarsus rather
than walking all the way here javelin
thank you walking there is slow common
and uncommon items will stop dropping at
level 30 so you're gonna get blue purple
or above so I mean at thirty once you
start getting like mass Oryx and stuff
that's really all you're going for I
mean if you get full epic you're only
going from s-works they've got mess
works and you're trying to like tweak
those and then get legendary so I mean
the blue and the purple like all not all
loot is
but after a while you're like come on
but I mean every games gonna do that but
at least taken whites and greens out of
their help some yes they've quick fix a
lot of bugs that do with dead quickly
mission so that's good for people like
jumping in and trying to help people and
then those crashing which kind of sucks
for that purpose right there's a random
stronghold option and it's fault a/c
because this is his article though with
no changes to stronghold balance it's
like I'm not sure why anyone would run
this because in iron mine is the one
everybody knows and runs quick the
others are just so much longer mm-hmm
they've fixed most most sound bug
situations server shut no messages
those were literally like every five
minutes and it'd be for two hours like
if you were using the mission for I was
just gonna pop up in Bothell and it's
like they want you to finish the
activity like you know go back to the
forwards or exit out or whatever like in
two hours but I don't need to see it all
the time maybe towards the end like hey
you got 30 minutes hey you got 15 you
got ten you got eight like if you got
ten minutes to finish an activity yeah
figure it out but outside of that you
should know bugs that makes your
ultimate look like it's full like when
you start a play session that's gone
because that was annoying a bear is it
it's always the first time and then it
was fine but it was really really is
this old I don't see the storm an
ultimate unlimited glitch on this the
one that glad got banned for her or the
no adult is he still banned actually I
don't know what I put in there yeah
basically it was like a two-week thing
she did get banned initially I guess it
was because of the storm but ever lived
it was a kind of massive situation
overall don't agree with it I mean let's
be real this is Bioware this is a glitch
in their game yeah and a guy for you
know doing a glitch you know that's
really messed up and I'm very
disappointed actually did that happen
but he's unbanned currently right now um
and again you know he's not that happy
you know he made it very clear you know
and in Philly should have been been and
the first place a lot of people agree
but I'm very concerned because I saw
that ultimate thing and nowhere on this
list
am I seeing the storm Colossus I mean
javelin um ultimate you know being able
to use that super over and over so if
that's still a case
then they're banning people for that
yeah we gotta pay attention you know
listen he said did he say exploit you
guys breaking a Community Guidelines
getting bad but the problem is this is
an issue that's a bug in their game it's
not a next play you know one's using I
mean these exploit taste preference was
like the loot cave that I heard you know
I'm saying I if it's a bug in the game
based on the developers and it's up to
the developer to fix that game and you
can't punish people for utilizing it
that's just what people are gonna do and
it's like you know knocking curta or
knocking code off the thing you think
everybody not gonna push atheon off the
wall you know it you don't getting a
glitch for doing that and there's PvP in
destiny where that would actually make a
difference when you can get vex
mythoclast and stuff there's no PvP in
this you only hurt your own enjoyment as
your farming something like that's
absolutely so we got to keep it true
anthem guys listen freely eagle listen
the prep here's the problem Philly and
in his prompt is he
this gaining as much as we love it right
has had a very rough start right you get
killed in the press you get killed
because there's a lot of fundamentally
flawed and broken things with the game
the last thing you want to be doing is
banning players skill ups like he and
his brother in the new layman gaming's
like anthem bands the only person still
straming it or something like the player
base and and the whole mentality is so
low right now it's such in a negative
media space you know last thing you need
to do is that so I get it to the letter
of the law which end-user agreement I
get it but other if you look at other
games destiny divisional and other stuff
if there are bugs by the developer right
this is a developer floor and players
are doing it right they're not using a
cheat code they're not using third-party
software that is on the developer to fix
an issue and that's not here so I'm
warning everybody skating been in there
exactly I've been like a
oh that's like--that's outside of the
game where you're kind of breaking
inputs to a point that is outside of
normal boundaries like that would be a
point where that's almost more than I
mean I didn't jump into it but from what
I've gathered like from what you're
saying I need to watch the video at some
point but it's just him using functions
or breaking something in it but again
it's that you're not affecting anybody
else's playtime but your own I mean if
you want to go what's that monkey punch
if you want to go and like farm Lakota
masterworks and run yourself out of like
time then you know that's like that's
kind of your own choosing it's like as
there's not PvE I feel like it was less
necessary than most games like division
if you've glitched something out you're
just gonna toroid people and you know
the occupy dark zone anyone like that
view or nil it's a P you can't say
exploit in a PvE gay you're not
affecting another play like you just say
like you're not if you doing something
that is giving you a distinct advantage
over another player on some type of PvP
I get that but this is literally just
you know something in the game that you
should be fixed to stop you from getting
unlimited supers right that's on the dev
there's no way around that but let's see
it says the lock people behind walls
again like stuff like this obviously
shouldn't be there bugs that made it
look like your ultimate bar so you can
prime Titan so you'll do more damage to
them overall that's a good thing because
Titans are like a big piece in the game
and there was just kinda kind of spongy
sit back snipe dumb post Hooper sit back
throw stuff at him but you couldn't get
the extra pieces on there which you
wanted to be able to do mm-hmm
mark of ruin works now I don't even know
gunslingers mark works now they've kind
of fixed the bugs I think those were
just some like buggies and that was the
thing like one of the guns where my
buddy had a pistol where he could like
dodge as the storm and dodge again and
have like you know a pistol shot hittin
for 50000 damage something and say that
he wasn't banned for but that's just
literally the same thing or it's like it
was double stacking whatever the bug the
buff was and he didn't people weren't
I mean it's cuz he went public with it
probably is why they felt like they
thought it was like it's just that was a
poor decision
melee is an ultimate
now do more damage thank you for my
interceptor and Ultimates as well like
sometimes you pump out an ultimate
you're like I'm like level damage going
into a hard content I should probably be
able to put some work in and it's like
less then I feel like it and then shout
out the policy on like the Ranger is a
weak class they need to buff it Ranger
cool down cool down wind wall and Ranger
dome actually block higher base damage
of macro master work bump weapons bumped
generally so the try to get things more
powerful give you a better feel which is
good things that we talked about in the
big stream which I haven't watched yet
but thanks to task C for wrapping it up
mm-hm difficulty balancing for Grand
Master two and three right now worth
your time cuz G Grand Master one can
drop master works and legendaries and
there's not really a worthwhile point
not like Grand Master 3 is gonna be like
hey you're gonna get like 6 legendaries
from this run suite you might get one
from GM 1 ok that might be more worth my
time there all right now it's not so
they gotta look into that stat page
being look into I don't know do you see
my tweet there was somebody put one
together it would be amazing like if I
can find that tweet of mine but they
just had like an overall view screen
like hey here's my resistances here's my
weapons and like kind of their little
buffs to him it's just like a big
overview of your character as opposed to
like having to go into each note and
then see what it is in there it's like
it's a UI thing and that's something I
think a division probably could use a
tweak on the UI as well but yeah that's
uh getting used to and this is again
where this it needed like 6 months to
bake it so yes it's clay in the base of
the game I do enjoy but it's play it
didn't need in time to bake and it
sucked because like I said I don't want
to make this a bad fence you know I love
the foundation of this game I love what
it was attempting attempting to do I
still think there's tremendous potential
and um you know I think they got a shot
they gotta turn it around I mean one
thing is that the dev team least gives
you confidence that they are very you
know responsive and reactive so March
12th this is coming you know next week
so this is a this is a big list this is
a lot of what people are one in fixed so
this is the
start let's get let's get the foundation
cleaned up you know I'm saying and now
you know just get that content you know
where I am worried about me worry about
May is a long time for you know a
substantial thing but you know at this
point let's get this bad boy working and
functional and let's not overheat no ps4
today but you've got more world events
coming more changes to respawning being
downed coming which is you know a good
thing
so more changes on top of the respawning
masterwork supporting gear like master
there are no support master works so
that's kind of an issue and new support
items coming looking into frequency of
store rotation will be drop cosmetics
that's a cool addition yes richer and
shout out to dy Knox Unleashed for the
follow up thanks drop rates being looked
at but they're waiting to see how common
uncommon removal goes so they're gonna
see like what Global's are like but
they're gonna test this out mm-hmm
several ministers a mass at reddit post
that I did look at for like every single
inscription so they really break some
stuff down there's a lot of craziness in
there yeah there's a health bug they
said it was supposed to be fixed and
then it wasn't and then Ben Irving came
out and said we thought it was fixed
it's not we're looking into it again and
that's kind of a big deal like that
he'll fix especially for certain classes
or like the colossus having different
like health bars and stuff up there
mmm-hmm co-op i mean that's a huge one
for the colossus so they said they're
looking at the ranger which they admit
is weaker than the other classes and
just more stuff coming so they are
trying they're gonna be supporting it
they've got the backing to try and be
like hey we're gonna support this thing
that they put money behind it it was a
long time in development it just got
taken out of the out of the oven too
early and it didn't set so like they
need they will keep supporting it and if
you didn't jump on it yet honestly maybe
it's time to wait till late how the next
couple of months go in patches i know
they're gonna be working their ass off
and cataclysms like you'll have a new
stronghold at that point you'll have
cosmetics you'll have the character
progression stuff that they're looking
into so there will be more then and it's
just it's a shame it released without
all
these things and with the poor lunch
like if it would have launched with
another stronghold the Cataclysm was
coming you know like a raid hey two
weeks later we're gonna have the
Cataclysm timing that felt like a better
full complete lunch like we're about
talk about another game that's just
gonna smash the doors off things there
would be in a better place in EA
probably just was the point where you
have to launch now and they're probably
like we don't want to things are broken
you have to okay here we go
and that's all that I just got to hold
on for the ride and unfortunately now
they're just in a level of crunch time
for probably like six months to try and
save this thing so I feel for the I feel
for Bioware I I don't think they wanted
to put something out that was broken if
they had the choice but there's time
constraints and things and that's what
it is so anthems got some work to do
there's another game though there's an
input network and it's called division
yeah where do you want to start I'm just
gonna leave this on screen because it's
kind of a cool image to see all the
stuff you got but where do you want to
start with what we got coming with
Division two next you know by the way
I'm out of town next week so I'm gonna
be the lady yeah man
so I'm gonna be doing my PC thing on my
own wait wait no no - you got some
there's been some developments thanks to
lower headaches I do I am the owner of a
free copy of the PC version just I
didn't ever get a chance to talk to you
I know you had the TCP stuff so I'm
playing on xbox predominantly but if you
do want to play and I said I do have a
copy now so shout out to Lord addict my
means hooking me up that AMD special to
AMD love deco soon as we start talking
we gonna get sixty five dizzy tweets
about how he hates Ubisoft so just
warning you guys now where's BK better I
need them anyway but um yeah man there's
a lot of stuff like this infographic is
a ton of stuff I'm not gonna go into
every ass because we'll be here all day
this is seriously
aka Longpoint right now but yeah
the gist of it you know gear score
specializations you know exotics are
coming back you know skill variants all
that stuff all shout out the Forte he's
doing a PC at Xbox to love it alright so
um yeah you know play equipment mods
they really break down that the basics
but what I actually want to dive into is
I wanted to give a shout out actually to
my boys although uh was actually in the
chat early he's got a great article up
right now and that's up on our site log
net which is on Lords of gaming net and
um basically what it is right now is
they had a state of the game stream
right and I would be full disclosure but
I've been pom-pom and for division they
got a work on a streams like no
disrespected no community manager it's
just that I come from Bungie and I know
what a stream you know saying that
high-level production and it's just they
got to work on that they got to work on
you know it's making a snazzy you know
saying like I'm not there with it but
anyway back to what I was at I got it up
on stream now so alright cool cool you
got em astray so um yeah man so pretty
much what it is right now there's a lot
going on you know as far as the um you
know what to do after level 30 right
that to me we know this raise enough
stuff but I didn't realize there was so
much more stuff yeah shout out that gave
me 48 air streams aboard its f thank you
for go to it I agree so I'm glad my man
PD he he stuck it out he wrote a great
article pretty much summarizing what
they talked about to get the juicy stuff
so pretty much what it is level 13
beyond so we what we did know is that
they remember that extra faction in the
black tusk is coming right so we get to
see how the map changes how things in
worlds here missions start now what he
says is that an individual world world
and division one world here made
everything harder but in Division two of
the world tiers are locked behind
strongholds which are a lock through to
invasion missions that you have to
complete now these strongholds which I
didn't realize are go in the game are
focal points throughout the leveling
process it's a complete world Tier three
you must complete the stronghold of
tidal basin that they want you to feel
like you're always under the gear score
to fill a challenge in the game
so it's a progression
right you've got to have that um you
know you got the stronghold you got the
invasion missions you see here you got
the Roosevelt Island the Capitol
building the district green area and
they got these requirements and gears
core requirements for that you know I
mean so this way it says it once you
makes the world feel alive it's a push
and pull dynamic with the factions
throughout the map and then once you get
to level 30 you go back to the base and
that's when you get this specialization
now as we explained last um last word
the specializations actually think of or
destiny guys think of them like a
subclass unlock right and you get to
pick which route you want to go and we
do know what the couple of content drops
they're gonna be adding more of these
very more planned
yeah man which is really cool and each
has their own patrie you know I'm saying
if you click on these images you'll see
you know a couple of stuff like that
they're talking about and it's just
really cool you know I think it's a
really cool in-game kind of mechanic
with that and um yeah man then they're
talking about you know what the world
tears now I don't know if you guys will
remember with the settlements in the
game their settlements in the game
there's people in the game that um
pretty much have to like you can assist
and and then with you you do jobs and
missions for them they actually help you
fighting like you can pull up if you're
getting you know besieged by a certain
faction you're out in the world you can
shoot a flare in the air and these
actual NPCs come and help you right
which is really cool so now they're
talking about with the as you go on with
these ropes here one they're talking
about bounties and then talking about um
also having the dailies and weekly it's
kind of like a destiny you're not I'm
saying and then there's a new thing when
I said mission to kill all 52 named
bosses and it's gonna be crazy like the
vibe that I'm getting right now there's
a random merchant also in Azeroth kind
of frame called Cass who says gear works
around a map it's kind of random you got
to find out where she's at
you know I'm saying so it's a lot of
stuff going on man and it's really cool
to see that every single time they're
adding more and more stuff and it's like
we already heard about the clan stuff
last week and I'm saying now we're
hearing about the world tears this week
we're hearing about the strongholds
we're hearing about the missions it just
seems like
stuff to do you know saying shout out
again to their petty marketing team
because as soon as season of The Drifter
launch boom here comes an info blast oh
here comes the trailer
boom here comes an info blast boom a
good this so Teddy but in a good way
like they're playing to win like that
but regardless of if it's gonna be
successful or not whatever happens it's
kind of funny to me that whoever's in
charge of the marketing team they are on
it they don't want you to forget this
games
it's pretty much what I got you know
listen at the end of the day we gotta
see you know if it's executed you know
correctly I mean if it executed well but
on paper as it stands it's a ton of
content it's a ton a ton of very content
a ton of stuff to keep grinding and I'm
we'll see we'll see we're getting we're
getting closer we got a march 20 what's
our release date looking like was its
15th because they're early is it next
Friday already
yeah its March 15 why am I thinking this
- 26 oh wow like heroes the next week oh
yeah this is it's okay it says initial
release date March 15th hold on I hate
it
double check getting the full like
three-day early access Gold Edition is
that what you're doing
oh yeah I'm no Super Deluxe extra cheese
extra sauce all that's going down mm-hmm
yeah hold on apparently I have to be old
enough to look at this website yeah like
how old am i guys come on I mean it says
initial release date March 15th I just
don't know why it says initial release
date yeah I wanted the early access
thing I got a I got a double check but
look shot the cat daddy shout-out to a
lot of people when you chat I mean I
think that this and we got to keep
expectations but I will say this shout
to war blackjack he said it for like if
this launch is fine it's
Forrest you know a strong launch not
major issues you know like the anthem
launch or whatever it's stuff like that
and as long as the game is functional
there's gonna be a strong base there's
gonna be a strong base for this there's
gonna be people like I said no we've had
this discussion about the you know boots
on the ground I want to get too deep in
there because we'll go forever on that
but at the end of the day we have to
remember that there is a strong base
that is going to love this style of game
play you know saying this is not for
everybody but there is a strong base
that loves it so again if they execute
there's a lot there's a couple of if you
know the launch is smooth for the most
part and things are working and they get
rid of the audio bugs and they get rid
of say because they had audio bugs too
like I got a kill call it true then it
was some glitches I mean there's some
ramps that I can't turn off up sideways
yeah there's stuff in the world like if
it's a slight incline like some in the
middle I just go off the left I'm a
hyung come on like so I mean there's
like world stuff like that that I feel
like it was almost something I really
didn't feel as much in Division one and
I feel like the world indeed too isn't
as polished and I can't quite figure out
why it did feel better than the open
beta so I saw a Boomslang he big
division guy previously he was saying
it's like something about it I don't
know it just feels different I jumped in
and it did feel a little snappier like
some of the stuff I was saying in the
private beta like something felt off and
it did feel better this time around for
me so that was something that I noticed
those like okay something's feel a
little more raid like kind of feeling
like I can kind of do what I'm trying to
try and want to do hold all Forte says
March 12th it's for the gold and
Ultimate Edition standard is the 15th oh
hey oh my life so once again I'm talking
about the holy it really gave anthem
crap of like the launch but it was a
week verses three days yeah there ain't
there continual continent is gonna be on
the same time for everybody if you get
that gold annual pass whatever you get
three days early access to each piece of
content to my knowledge yes is I mean
that's kind of one of those things like
if you get three days early access to a
raid and destiny
that'd be kind of a thing so I'll be
kind of curious what that does for
just came to the feel if wouldn't alot
just be like you get the past now I
guess I gotta wait three days let me go
wash it on somebody else's it's just
some of those like when it's big content
drops it's annoying that like hey here's
this new thing coming out well I'll go
watch the streamers play for three days
first you'll pass and that's a no and
that's an annoyance not even just
specifically calling division that's
just everybody
yeah like the time peace of like paying
a little bit early or whatever like if
you're gonna have content if I pay for
it just you know let me get the content
at the same time like paying like my you
know three days early is kind of that's
a weird that's for me personally that's
a new thing that seems like the whole
industry's doing no this is across the
board this whole pay to get in early
like everyone's doing it yeah I mean
anthem did it for peace or there and
that's them for ei trying to sell their
ei origin premiere be like hey get on PC
a week early and you get to beta test it
apparently but that was a different
thing mm-hmm
so we'll see I mean it's got a lot I
mean as I go through you get the armor
sets and stuff sometimes I feel
ridiculously overwhelmed by like like
having to scroll through the weapon on
the side to see what perks are available
like the UI for me is the thing that I
would like to see tweaked because trying
to see what information is going on with
my character and takes a long time to
figure out like that's my piece that
sadly like why there I know destiny is
simplified mm-hmm but man the UI is just
clean and it works right well that's one
thing for me that I and almost the way
it was before you had the three big
pieces up top saying like weapon damage
armor and I know they kind of changed
the way that stuff works but there's
just so the and there is a ton of stats
and you can min/max like crazy in this
game which is a good thing for those who
want to write slowly a nice piece about
it but unfortunately you get to the
point of like what what's going on with
my character it played out there are
pieces it's like Braille text like it's
it's it's hieroglyphics look this is an
RPG man like you know like this is so
like it like I just need a point on my
character and maybe I just didn't find
the right menu to say like the character
like hey Plus script percentage
currently is like
plus 25% it just adds it all together if
there's and I feel like there was a
screen like that in d1 and I just didn't
dig that deep in the menus to talk about
the same and we talked about would be
xanthan menus I never stood the anthem
you guys good either we're both Xbox one
blade I'm like how is that like it like
effects or means no baby that's why they
said like that's when they're looking at
like the tweet that I sent out that
somebody had like made their own
character in full screen I was like that
that should be a thing like I like
whoever did this image like talk to them
pay him some money so they're cool to
use it and put that crap in anthem
because that's the same thing it's a
it's a main screen saying hey I've got
poison resistance a narc resistance my
weapon over here has you know a bonus to
these damages I've got bonuses to my
general suit and you could see
everything in one place like if I want
to deep dive into a certain weapon cool
but I need a place to get a general
overview of what's going on is all I'm
going for and and there may be just
honestly a piece of the menu that I
missed which privately on it is gear
score there's all of thats there like it
literally they're like we got to stop
acting like this dude it's so hard to
fight it's just you're not used to their
menus you just don't play the game
custom to what you're accustomed to but
it's a little bit yeah but there's I
mean up like from I just little things
like double-click on on the weapons to
get the mods in like let me just go to
and click on it and like then I can pick
like what I'm gonna put in there was
just a single in doubles and so just
little feels of the UI for me that are
tweaks but I mean overall like I finally
I think I got a decent sniper so I've
putting some damage out when I ran
through I ran the level 30 again this
time with the grenade launcher no I did
the crossbow and it's still that feel
like you break the armor those dudes die
fast like and it felt when I had
whatever build that was which is three I
don't know what the gear scar was like
350 ish somewhere there i know domme
rifles are no joke you know i have me a
marksman rifle oh man wait which are
skills were you using by the way I'm
curious so I went survivalist for the
end game one so I had literally both the
healing
dude nearly little ball and then I had
the armored drone so I went I had both
on that one but normally for me I would
are an armored drone because I can float
even though it is risky because I didn't
have a little ball that I could use and
then also I had the turret because I
liked absurd to give me some counter
action between like my position and
somebody else's because I'll run solo a
lot so that's usually my built for those
pieces is another direction of fire that
they're gonna turn out for a little
while yeah
and that's just one of those things I
wish I could like beefed up and give
some health to so but yeah that was my
one is usually health for me which just
seems like totally required because man
the armor like packs that you get or the
armor that you put back on yourself that
takes a little while yeah you need some
way to heal up like big-time oh yeah
they make it a I don't you mean yeah you
get tagged you're like whoa mmhmm yeah
so yeah that was my - what were you
running I'm right now actually messed
with two different I still love my
sniper - I think it's really powerful
okay how is that thing because you have
to manually target and I kind of noticed
that with the other turret where if like
I'm looking around and I hit a and that
basically will target the thing right
how is that with the sniper have that
like again once the sniper it's super
powerful once you line up what you're
aiming at right
so basically shoot any enemy you'll see
over his head in your cases probably and
press e on console it's any like press
right bumper right but then once I press
right bumper the sniper turret then
lines the person up right now once that
that means he's gonna pay attention to
where where he's going now once I tell
it again like he pops himself out and I
press that right boom and I bum again
then it fires the shot so you still have
to fire yourself you have to manually
control at least that's how I felt on
console I don't know I mean I'll try it
at some point baby I just super powerful
super powerful you can take chunks down
man it is very you just gotta coordinate
how you're gonna do it it's really
effective so I was doing that I messed
around with oh I messed around the first
time I did the role of mine so I'm not a
fan of either like I don't like it as
much it's powerful but I'm like yeah and
I really didn't fit my play style so
what my new play style is now I'll do
sniper turret for long distance zoning
and then when
you know how you always get those NPCs
that run down on you I'm just crazy
yeah what I do is I use cuz in the open
beta they gave us another class and it's
this thing when you put on the ground
it's like a bomb but it's like almost
like this styrofoam thing it is sticks
them in place so anybody who's a gather
Kim launcher and you get yep yes so I
throw the kevlar to death so they wanna
rush all right come rush now you gonna
stay in place and you gonna get this
work I love it now I just wish it lasts
like a second Atul it probably last
about yeah it was pretty short I did try
that once I think Ozma because the Kim
launcher they opened up for the open
beta yeah it felt it felt short like
brief like I need to lock down like
something it needs to last for a long
time what what I'm hoping is a lot of
the upgrade paths were not available in
the beta you don't say a lot I'm curious
to see you and you can your skills right
I saw that kind of what is see where
that goes man and like I said the
specializations that's something that
excited me like I said the gear says
again this hesitant and I said listen
this is very much RPG mechanics now I
get it
but you guys not liking you know menus I
can't all gay if you don't like Maggie's
you don't like Maggie's I can't you know
argue that that's just but it's deep
like that's what you there's like you
know skills you know about Destiny's
supposed to have these boys got it you
don't say it just a matter you just
gotta dive in it and it's how serious
you want to take this game right if you
really want to get in there you want to
speck towards that build you can do that
you don't say if you want even with the
ARMA sets like every like Davitt that
destiny just playing around with these
little you know armored division been
doing it like that it's like they get a
trying the visitors looking at the Alma
says like fam get on my level you not
nowhere near what we're doing like that
legendary gear has two or three stacks
based on what you put on and how it
effects so it again they're way more
advanced with true RPG you can no life
Jess
figuration right I mean that
recalibration you've got skills with
skills mods and scale variants I mean
your perks and stuff like that like
that's the cool thing too and that's one
thing I think anthem didn't have it
launched which again early baking
absolutely the actual pilots get like
points and skills that like they took
out and I think that's something of that
progression to bring it back the perks
that you like hey you unlock this and
then when you open a chest you have a
50% chance at this and then the way the
mods work for like scopes or things like
I unlocked half of those just by playing
and you're not waiting on these drops
again you're just like hey I have this
scope I can always put on my weapons and
when the bots the percentages or other
places which you know I'm kind of okay
with yeah I was hated like oh I'm
waiting for another scope so I can put
on this weapon or buy it it's like mods
are there which like they've done a lot
of good things cran this is and this is
a game acting yeah anyway talk about
crap we haven't even talked about exact
there's so much stuff I'm not even talk
about it's in this game like I said four
features it there's no sorry I got I got
a quote again features nothing's messing
with this game the question is just
gonna be execution that's really all is
everything that they're offering is
everything all the other games are
offering and more combined just features
just just base game I'm not even talking
about Mo's base game like none of these
what destiny watch what is that I mean
anthem total crafting I'm saying
but again the recalibration they have
exotics now is it gonna be exotics like
destiny you know damn well it's not
great and and that's kind of the
difference of like what are these things
I mean the legendaries and anthem aren't
like mostly game changes I mean they add
like a variance on it but I mean you
don't have like a shiny gold weapon or
you don't have a fireball that now
splits into three you don't have like
those the flare of like word cliff coil
that is a different animal entirely
absolutely anything I mean those are
pieces and like they're way exotic armor
like some of that stuff will well crap
your new little mini art turret sounds
terrifying oh yeah those are those are
game changer pieces and some of the
exotics they'll be like hey here's more
damage or an extra perk and there'll be
a thing to go for but I mean really it's
like the exotics will be like the cherry
on top of like a sundae that you have
configured to like right you know the
max like so you get to customize every
little ounce of your sundae every little
sprinkle every little graham cracker
flavor chocolate chip and then the
cherry on top is exotics with your gear
sets and everything else I mean know
like your time that you can spend in
this game if you like this and it
launched as well
you could lose so many hours in this
thing because you're gonna go world tier
two worlds here three worlds here for
your zone dark sound like they have a
lot they really do so if this is your
jam and you're gonna be jamming in it
for a while and like I said don't
underestimate the the base that's all
I'm saying just don't underestimate the
base we're gonna learn a lot when they
launch we're gonna learn I mean like ft
and buyer were like yeah a plan yeah but
I guess I know you in the minority I
know Dizzy's in evanora a couple people
I know is in the minority the rest of
the world is ready for this game like
they've been wanting this is the
division game they wanted and I'm
telling y'all right now I call this I'm
just keeping quiet long as they launch
right so people better get low the other
games better get low and I'll tell right
if they launch right and there's nothing
fundamentally broken and it's working
watch out for your player base that's
all I can we're gonna revisit these
conversations and I'm a screenshot all
these messages dizzy saying I'm a
screenshot I'm just gonna come back with
the numbers and I'm gonna say remember
that stuff y'all was saying and I'm
telling us they're coming they are
coming trust me so let's see how this
plays out yep so yeah I was like if it's
on the 12th I guess I got a looking to
see if I'm gonna play it that way or not
cuz they don't have a couple days before
I leave but yeah sounds like and that's
kind of thing those like if I do the 12
but I've also got like the allegiance
quest to work through thorns gonna get
started next week I was like I might
save division till I get back honestly
cuz I'll be gone for Thursday through
Sunday so shadows everybody watching
right now won't be able to a last word
next week just cuz I'll be out I will be
trying to look into xur from far because
I'm taking my computer with me because
that's the start of the 9 so I do want
to see what that's all about if I make a
video up there
but yeah like I mean as you're saying
this thing has so much depth if you want
it like if you played level 1 through 30
you play the story you kind of see the
black dust takes over you kind of fight
some of them back in missions and that
alone might be enough for some people
and that's probably still gonna be a
pretty lengthy 4050 hours easy mm-hmm
and then if you start like dabbling in
stuff there's probably gonna be more if
you don't have an eight-person group
which by the way putting six people
together for a destiny raids sometimes
can be hard finding eight is gonna be a
struggle for some people for sure though
there's gonna need to be like division
to lfg net yeah one day probably
matchmaking right you think Oh on a raid
would be okay if the raids have a favor
worthwhile you shouldn't have
matchmaking because it might be a train
wreck or you need voice talking or what
so that's kind of the that's the balance
of like how hard is the mechanics of the
raid to the point where like you need to
communicate like I mean if you think of
the you know taking king fights and
stuff like that like you have to chat
this so if it's go point where you need
that then I mean lfg or matchmaking or
something like that maybe a thing to
look at but even if you don't get to
play the raids there sounds like just a
butt ton of stuff to do roaming around
world tiers leveling up in there and
stuff like that so one of my issues is I
like how there's a lot where I don't
have to run into the dark zone because
that feeling still sucks for you uh well
no I'm saying like as a solo player it
will suck I mean I don't guess I
disagree with that but that's just your
experience and III can't disagree with
your experience I just I can again a lot
of stuff comes down to understanding and
in if you're willing to put in the time
and understand the game works I don't
believe you're I got a call for oh but
you I love you I'm play dumb I got a ton
of division-one probably in like in the
dark soon runs eyes I was like know who
that is no longer a pig no that's not a
thing
but in gay y'all living in Division one
pass you see you see it's not the same
no but all I'm saying it's not even that
I'm just saying as a solo player in the
dark
whether it's normalized whether it's not
if it is especially normalized if you
are by yourself against other people as
a team this is from a solar player's
perspective solely nothing else the same
way gambit sucks as a solo player the
dark zone can suck because they are
smaller and a team can get to you
quicker so there are certain things
about that darks I'm like hey the higher
levels will farther away so if I'm
running around like level-1 level-2 kind
of doing low level dark zone stuff
because I could I don't it's a smaller
area for me to try and run away because
oh yeah there's a team running around in
there I got to put you onto some stuff
some loadouts okay like and then we'll
get to it but it's like I'm just saying
as a solo player I was like literally
one of the first things that just
reminded me of it too quickly in the
beta I was running around hey explore in
the dark so it took me literally ten
minutes for a team of three on a manhunt
to run by mode me over she came back out
again at a different door running around
they ran around found me again it was
like that piece of the manhunt if that's
a piece of content not everything's in
the dark zones which is good blur me if
I don't have to spend my time in there
and a lot of it you said the strongholds
they in games the raids the people like
those won't be there but dabbling in a
piece of content that will be towards
the end game that's one of those things
as a you know somebody who may not
always have somebody to play with where
that is definitely a struggle in that
place because yoko Stearns is has a solo
player absolutely and that's for the
people and that's was like i mean come
on that was me last night
I am the solo guy so I was like so if
you got a team running in there
coordinated play with each other that I
can see having some awesome battles
because it's closer and you could like
hey we're gonna run up to these manhunt
guys and we can probably catch them what
does a solo player I'm like please God
don't find me like it's literally that
because it's just like it's defeating to
be like hey I finally killed some guys
and some of the stuff in the new dark
zone does you get to hold on to it but
it's the good stuff you're still gonna
have to extract so so feel that you said
they made one for every preference not
mine
you could have an occupied where
everything is on the board you have your
normalized one and then I want my PvE
one a lot of my PvE only dark side then
you can ask for Eurasian see that I know
you're not playing it
here's the big what Philly Eagle is
talking about is that each Dark Soul
right when he said every preference
there's the close-quarters one big long
sightlines oh let's just say like until
you gotta find your bill that you're
actually comfortable with that you can
actually go up against some groups and
still do damage you're I'm saying and as
well as use the PvE aspect to your event
this strategy it is is to me what you're
saying is the equivalent of me jumping
in comp getting squashed my first time
and they're saying si I'm never coming
back go jumping comp solo tell me how
much you get squashed but that could
affect apply to any game if you don't
know what you that's right that's also
my that's just my point is the fact that
any place that I'm trying to get loot
not in a PvP where like loot is like
either for winning or losing like it's a
point to where if I'm going into an
activity area where I can get some loot
that may benefit me but I can get a
chance to get it stripped away because
I'm running by myself now that hurts
that's one aspect that's not the whole
new dog zone this again there's loot
that you have to bring back that old
traditional way and there's non what you
call it look there's not for might like
end up my suspicion because at least the
way the drops working when I played the
good stuff had to still get extracted
the normal like that's okay what am I
gonna spin the endgame in okay fine one
month from now I want you to walk in the
dark zone by yourself and tell me how
that experience goes bringing on some
division because there's a lot of
missing on ass word no that's all I'm
saying is we want lunch anthem stuff of
a dealer with the des idees we gonna
bring some nice and guess I'm gonna
bring a panel because clearly people
have never played this game understand
how things work so we gonna have to
change that up start in the next couple
of weeks now dat division launched cuz I
am tired of this slander no I have a
very specific circumstance I just got
done praising most of this game I'm just
saying the dark zone for me especially
because they literally have three you
could have a PDE you could have your
normal eyes then you could have your
occupied you literally could
serve the world at that point even the
solo player who just wants to be like
hey the dark zone but she might want to
go a bag took the one time everything
sucks
I got my bag taken six thousand times in
Division one and that's why I hated it
there too so let's let that feeling of
like just getting jacked by guys that
are running around trolling people cuz
they're bored okay so now that's what
it'll say one month from lunch I want
you to go into the division to the dark
zone by yourself and tell me how that
feels it's literally the equivalent me
to a shadow thrown by myself one time
getting wrecked by the first couple of
ads and then throwing my controller and
say there's sucks that's something you
can't eventually get better at you can
get better at you just don't know what
you're doing and we're going to bring
some people in to educate you so that's
going to be the goal that's the new
thing okay if you're fully maxed now if
you're fully stacked and maxed out and
three people are fully stacked and maxed
out I'm sorry but my hunch is you're
gonna lose that battle nine times out of
ten if not more I'm gonna bring some
people in starting next equals ill in
numbers just Reavers one you're gonna
lose I'm gonna bring some people ad
because there's too much slander it's
too much education good or people still
talk about Division one stuff we have to
bring up I've heard the anthem crew it's
time for the division to move from the
bottom half of last third to the middle
it's right educated information and
that's what we're gonna do starting next
not next week the week after was all
head play weekend is about week after we
will put Division two right there in
bullet point number two and thank you
for the builds will engulf deal people
don't understand that's why I'm just
laughing I'm just like it's just so much
miss information and people are acting
like this is fact this is how we're just
trying to argue one point on me and I
don't because but that's your whole
purpose of say like you're not going to
play it is just no that's literally not
how many other things that I just say
we're good you're gonna dive in I'm
gonna enjoy the fact that I can go run
strongholds and work on my builds in
recalibration and raids are thing that I
don't worry about this I'm just saying
that peace of the dark zone still like
burned me and then I walked in and I'm
just like it still has that feeling
there's like 85% of the game this
and I'm looking forward to a lot of it
now I'm gonna play it because believe me
I'll play all these but that's just the
one piece that still I'm saying as a
that's why and that's and they're
arguing under that like a solo player
walking into the dark zone is gonna have
a great time and I'm like that yeah yeah
yes they came just because you had a bad
experience does not scar it for the rest
of the world as I'm trying to say it's
literally equivalent of jumping in
copper trial for the first time getting
rekt and saying taking your ball and go
home because you had a bad experience
that's what I'm trying to say I get it
it may not be for you but all I'm trying
to say is you don't understand every
aspect so that you can get better as a
solo player that's all I'm saying
let's try to get the information to try
to get better as it sucks that's all I'm
saying now after that then we can do
bring some people in that's fine
I was very specific on one point so that
was all but I'm looking forward to a lot
of this so there's gonna be not enough
time for me to play all these three
games anthem sounds like it may have
some waiting to do so not a big rush it
feels like I'm doing some of that stuff
and then Dusty's gonna probably have
it's like weekly shot of a quest and you
know Tuesday and Friday and then I'll be
probably grinding a lot of division too
so in the time that you jump on PC feel
free to say hello but I mean hey I'm
glad you got a copy so at least we'll be
able to jump in a little bit cuz you'll
probably know life it on xbox and then
probably be on my pace on PC so they'll
probably be alright any nice if they had
crossover then you can just jump in with
me and just man I can't wait for next
gen just in general even cross-platform
I know can have its issues of like
certain thing cost save too many people
have api's and things like that you just
pulled data I am I have my stuff go like
that shouldn't be an issue
oh I think we're there we're right at
the cusp we're right now in the
transitionary phase but well shut up
everybody who hung out with us for three
damn hours is like our log longest last
word blog point probably ever yo vote in
the community can we get division out of
the last topic let's get a move
it's shocking
I'm gonna move yeah it's Jesus Christ we
gotta bring it up I don't know if I
can't put it at the top I can't put it
above destiny but I've put it on number
two I'll put it at number two because
right now I feel like it's about to earn
that actually broke it into box let's
get the gate I got no cutting plus the
game fell to the bottom airplane all
right cool
we can work with that I can do that so
all right guys
Missouri is gonna be live in literally
five minutes I'm gonna switch over and
jump on that but you guys know where to
find us it's Eve on ttis everywhere for
me it's twitch Twitter YouTube if you
guys haven't followed like subscribe all
the good stuff please do it helps us out
of course and everything that we are
trying to do and to all of you guys out
there in both chats it's been awesome
this morning thank you guys for the
support and hanging with us for this
forever long discussion um follow my
twitter and if you guys see the YouTube
videos I'm working on audio places for
this it's not been approved on all
platforms but there's a couple it's out
there so even just like anchor fm it's
an app you could listen literally listen
to it there and I'm waiting for like the
big stuff like iTunes and Spotify and
cross my fingers that happens but audio
only is coming so that's in the works
nice what about you questionnaire so I'm
great that's really cool that we're
trying to get there going yeah me same
old deal meet at Laura kognito on
Twitter all that good stuff
the Lord's Day returns on Sunday and we
shall return with the multiverse podcast
got a little new series I'm doing where
I bring uh got a new podcast some that
maybe people haven't heard of and these
guys they've been doing it for a little
bit and they kind of have a unique feel
more of the time is good because Captain
Marvel is out and they kind of do gaming
as well as our comics and stuff like
that so shout out to anchorman v might
be the truth and I believe Nick more say
so um yeah we're gonna have remanding
you know do a little history some gaming
latest topics what's going on in the
industry I think Sony's also um dabbling
with more remote play and also streaming
two devices kind of the Xbox we have us
and stuff so we'll have the topics about
you know hold on
you're very topics gonna go so check us
out Sunday 1:00 p.m. Eastern also check
out the website if you guys haven't
already you know Lords of gaming net as
you seen
yeah PD has some great articles
hopefully you know I'm trying to get
some more Ebonics walkthroughs up there
man get that going that'd be great
try to try to nudge them in that
direction but hey alright if you don't
wanna but all jokes aside man I
appreciate the love it's been cool we
got some great stuff coming with that
and yeah let's look forward towards to
Sunday and I also am going to see um
what you call a Captain Marvel as well
on Saturday so I can let me know your
thoughts when you see it for sure
absolutely that's all I got alright well
that is the bond to son Lord Lord
kognito for the last word at number 52
one year's worth for sure thank you guys
for being on the ride and hopefully many
more to come so on that word that is the
last word I'm out peace